mais bien cher aux abonnés pardonnez-moi
car j'ai péché
je dois tout recommencer la vidéo je
l'ai efface
oui le vous l'avez remarqué donc le
dernier des bonnes cages est pénitence
effectivement a disparu ce n'est pas
Youtube qui l'a supprimé c'est moi parce
que l'auteur de la vidéo que je
débloquais a décidé de retirer sa propre
vidéo donc ma vidéo n'a plus vraiment de
raison d'exister voilà donc des Bunka
j'ai pénitence visiblement à cet effet
car on arrive à faire changer d'avis les
gens
je m'y attendais pas mais bref du coup
bah faut que je recommence parce que il
y a plus que 13 stations à ma pénitence
donc il faut bien que je refasse ma 14e
station
je croyais être en être débarrasser
bonjour à toutes et à tous
bienvenue donc pour des bunks et
pénitence si vous êtes nouveau sur la
chaîne des Bunka j'ai pénitence c'est
surtout à propos de la pénitence pas
tellement à propos du des bunkage
sachant je
m'afflige des contenus si vous voulez
tellement horrible tellement redondante
tellement
pas intéressant en fait que le côté des
bunkages finalement c'est pas ça qui est
drôle ce qui est drôle c'est de me voir
souffrir voilà
donc bienvenue pour des Bunka j'ai
pénitence la série de vidéos sur
entracte science où je suis mal poli
malveillant et où je débunk à peine des
contenus qui sont horribles à regarder
donc je pars avec un énorme a priori sur
les contenus que je m'afflige parce que
c'est le but c'est le but c'est c'est
des choses que je dont je dois être au
courant en fait je m'inflige des choses
dont je dois être au courant mais je
veux pas et là aujourd'hui on va
s'infliger l'effondrement de la théorie
de l'évolution de Charles Darwin parce
que c'est important de préciser de
Charles Darwin rien que sur cette page
il y a des il y a à boire et à manger je
rappelle les deux règles de débunka j'ai
pénitence faut que la vidéo ait plus de
succès que les vidéos moyennes de ma
chaîne donc là on est sur 80 000 vues
c'est rare quand j'atteins les 81000
vues très honnêtement je dis pas que ça
n'est jamais arrivé mais c'est rare de
toute façon l'effondrement de la théorie
de l'évolution de Charles Darwin elle
existe en un millier d'exemplaires sur
Internet c'est la vidéo créationniste
c'est le boss final du créationnisme sur
Youtube elle existe en milieu
d'exemplaires à chaque fois YouTube la
supprime elle repop ailleurs c'est une
hydre vous voyez vous coupez une tête il
y en a cinq qui repoussent c'est donc en
tout elle doit avoir des millions de
vues cette vidéo vous l'avez forcément
vu vous l'avez forcément vous en avez
forcément entendu parler vous avez
forcément vu une version abrégée qui
s'appelle 11 minutes l'effondrement de
la théorie enfin l'effondrement de la
théorie de l'évolution en 11 minutes
c'est un petit extrait de cette vidéo là
de ce documentaire là elle est publiée
sur une chaîne qui s'appelle capitaine
Albator qu'on a déjà vu dans des bunks
et pénitence mais ce n'est pas lui
l'auteur de ces documentaire vous allez
voir que c'est un VHS RIB dégueulasse
qui confirme enfin qui illustre qui ne
confirme rien mais qui illustre
parfaitement ce que je n'arrête pas de
répéter à longueur de temps qui est le
créationnisme utilise des arguments
usés c'est du créationnisme des années
60 c'est tout est repompé tout le
créationnisme sur Internet et repompé du
créationnisme chrétien des années 50
nord-américain
c'est il suffit d'ouvrir n'importe quel
livre de Richard dokkins même ceux des
années 70 pour avoir un débunkage de
tout ça
pareil pour Dieu la science et l'épreuve
d'ailleurs j'en profite je ne ferai pas
des bonnes cages et pénitence sur due à
la science et l'épreuve parce que j'ai
déjà lu le passage au moins le passage
sur la biologie ma tolérance à la
douleur assez limite tout de même donc
Dieu la science et les preuves je ne
vais pas en faire un des Bunka j'ai
pénitence parce que j'ai déjà j'ai déjà
lu le truc donc ça tue un peu le concept
de débloquage et pénitence qui est que
je m'affiche des choses que je ne veux
pas m'infliger là en l'occurrence je me
le suis déjà infligé parce que j'en
avais envie et donc j'espérais y trouver
des arguments puisque le livre est censé
être nouveau j'espérais y trouver des
arguments nouveaux et bien non
idem vous prenez n'importe quel livre de
Richard dokkins vous prenez n'importe
quelle vidéo n'importe quel de mes
débunkers et pénitence sur n'importe
quel contenu créationniste vous y avez à
des bonnes cages d'absolument tout ce
qu'ils disent c'est des AR
usé le créationnisme c'est des arguments
usés c'est pour ça que je comptais
arrêter des bunkers et pénitence après
la 14e vidéo mais je peux pas parce
qu'elle a été supprimée parce que je me
suis supprimé comme un
bébé j'essaye encore d'être un peu poli
maintenant parce que il peut y avoir des
nouveaux sur la chaîne qui connaissent
pas des bonnes cages et pénitence je
vais je vais avoir un langage Chartier
il est possible que je m'énerve beaucoup
une heure de vidéo une heure de vidéo
c'est on est parti c'est si on applique
le principe d'asymétrie de Brandolini
j'en ai pour 4h à des bunker 7 daube
ça va être long ça va être long rien que
regardez rien que ça rien que rien que
le titre donc je disais vous avez deux
Charles Darwin donc déjà on admet on
admet sans aucun problème qu'on va se
focus sur Charles Darwin et ça théorie
de l'évolution à lui alors que sa
théorie de l'évolution à 150 ans elle
est loin d'être à jour on admet déjà
qu'il y a que la sélection naturelle
dont on va parler alors qu'il y a plein
de mécanismes dans la théorie de
l'évolution la sélection naturelle ne
justifie pas tout dans la théorie de
l'évolution ce n'est pas le seul
mécanisme que la théorie de l'évolution
que la théorie de l'évolution propose
mais on va se focuser sur la petite
partie de Charles Darwin a fait parce
que c'est facile c'est facile de
critiquer un truc qui a été fait il y a
150 ans bande de blaireaux bah oui quand
on n'a pas d'arguments bah on
sélectionne la partie qu'on est capable
de critiquer bah oui évidemment si ça a
été fait il y a 150 ans c'est facile à
débanquer bah oui mais bon
la théorie synthétique de l'évolution ça
vous dit quelque chose vous savez la
version moderne de la le bruit de
l'évolution celle où on a inclu
l'épigénétique la sélection sexuelle la
dérive génétique la Pan enfin les tous
les principes de la génétique des
populations qui n'existaient pas à
l'époque de Darwin Darwin connaissait
même pas la génétique tout court
donc bref on a tellement on a tellement
progressé en matière de connaissance sur
la théorie de l'évolution mais non là on
va rester sur Charles par win parce
qu'on aime bien taper sur Charles Darwin
parce que on était on est des
créationsnistes chrétiens alors on aime
bien taper sur le Messie ben oui mais
vous êtes convaincus que Charles Darwin
est le Messie de la théorie de
l'évolution ce n'est pas le cas
et même s'il y a des gens qui vous ont
fait croire que c'était le cas bah ces
gens se sont trompés
bref donc à boire et à manger sur cette
voilà des Illuminati on veut tuer en
voilà sur la miniature donc on va encore
bouffer du complot évidemment il y a du
complot je rappelle que dans le monde il
y a que 20 pays
sur tous les pays du monde il y en a que
20 dans lequel la théorie de l'évolution
est généralement admise par plus de 50%
de la population je parle même pas de
tout le monde et évolutionniste je dis
juste il y a que 20 pays dans le monde
ou plus de 50% de la population pense
que la théorie de l'évolution est la
meilleure explication qu'on a à la
biodiversité
20 pays c'est pas beaucoup c'est très
peu il y a pas là il y a pas la Chine ni
l'Inde dans ces pays je précise
immédiatement il y a ni la Chine ni
l'Inde dans ces 20 pays ça vous donne
une idée de à quel point waouh le
complot mondial le complot mondial pour
que la théorie de l'évolution dans les
créationsnistes sont très très largement
dominants dans le monde mais alors genre
beaucoup on en avait parlé on a déjà
expliqué tout ça avec des sources dans
une vidéo qui s'appelle le dessin
intelligent donc je vais pas revenir
là-dessus donc non le monde est
créationniste le monde est créationniste
et j'ai déjà mis mon petit pouce vers le
bas évidemment par principe par principe
parce que je et je m'attend donc à faire
mon grand bingo du créationnisme bas de
plafond à savoir les mutations
bénéfiques ça n'existe pas grand
classique les mutations ça peut pas être
bien c'est les gens qui ont trop regardé
X-Men tu vois et qui croient que la
génétique c'est que ils ont vu X-Men
donc ils comprennent la génétique non
les mutations bénéfiques ça existe les
amylases qui vous de digérer l'amidon le
ce qui vous permet de digérer le lait
aussi ce sont des mutations bénéfiques
qui ont eu lieu les
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autre bah donner le
meilleur exemple que j'ai c'est toujours
la drépanocytose la drépanocytose qui
est provoquée par qui est donc une
maladie du sang provoquer par une
mutation mais qui vous protège aussi de
la malaria si vous vivez dans un milieu
riche en malaria donc en fait la
polarité d'une mutation à savoir est-ce
qu'elle est bénéfique ou maligne bah ça
dépend pas de la mutation en fait c'est
pas intrinsèque à la mutation ça dépend
de l'environnement tout dépend de
l'environnement c'est à dire que la même
mutation s'il y a une mutation qui vous
rend qui vous rend pas albino parce que
albino c'est quand même dur de survivre
on va dire à l'état sauvage en étant
albinos mais s'il y a une mutation qui
qui fait que vous vos parents étaient
noirs et que votre peau devient blanche
dans ce qu'on appelle du le cysties du
leucistisme
si vous êtes le cystique vous allez
avoir un inconvénient si vous vivez sous
le soleil brûlant d'Afrique par contre
si vous vivez dans les contrées si vos
parents ont émigré en Suède par exemple
bon bah clairement ça marche vous voyez
c'est une question d'environnement c'est
une question d'ailleurs vous allez avoir
un avantage sur vos parents qui est que
vous allez mieux absorber le peu de
rayons UV qui enfin le peu de
rayonnement solaire qui arrive sur vous
et du coup vous allez mieux synthétiser
la vitamine D
donc la même mutation dépend son
avantage va dépendre de l'environnement
donc on va retrouver ce grand bingo de
la mutation bénéfique ça n'existe pas je
suis sûr qu'on va retrouver
le fameux c'est la sélection naturelle
ou rien alors que c'est pas vrai la
théorie de l'évolution ne postule pas
que c'est la sélection naturelle ou rien
il y a plein d'autres mécanismes que la
sélection naturelle
l'effondrement de la théorie de Darwin
me fait penser que on va évidemment se
limiter à un nombre de piliers assez
limité la paléontologie a priori n'a pas
déontologie va avoir un rôle
prépondérant dans ce à vue de miniature
non mes trêve de bavardage parce qu'on a
du boulot commençons
commençons comment ça j'ai vraiment pas
envie de cliquer sur ce sur ce truc ah
oui et puis je reste en mode blanc comme
ça le contour blanc parce que il y a pas
de raison qu'il y a que moi qui souffre
vous allez morfler
va peut-être mettre en accéléré hein on
va on va accélérer un peu
la qualité regardez ce VHS trip à 360 PC
horrible
vitesse de lecture normale
on va mettre en 1.5 et on va voir on va
voir
le professeur Philippe Johnson de
l'université de Berkeley c'est un peu
rapide c'est un peu rapide
[Musique]
déjà on commence par un truc que je
déteste le storytelling au lieu de
commencer de cette direct dans le pâté
tu vois on te raconte une histoire de
merde une anecdote à la con tous les
youtubeurs font ça et je trouve ça
horrible à chaque fois je trouve que
c'est une torture
là je m'attends à entendre après ça je
m'attends à attendre Nord VP merde
au fait est-ce que je vous ai parlé
demeure VPN mère tu vois après la petite
anecdote pourrie qui sert à rien au
début Nord VP merde retour au sujet
abonne-toi mets la cloche on repère
encore
déjà donc on commence par du
storytelling à la con alors ça ça
je pense que cette rencontre de page a
été un moment décisif pour beaucoup
d'entre nous chacun se pose à des
questions sur la théorie de l'évolution
et chacun a apporté ses idées
personnelles au débat ce qui nous a
permis subitement d'aborder les choses
avec un regard tout à fait
fait neuf
évidemment le
grand moment un grand moment du bingo
créationniste évidemment c'est
c'est la sortie de contexte le truc
préféré des créationsnistes c'est
Stephen jegould ils adorent citer
Stephen gigoule donc Stephen gigould qui
a proposé la théorie des équilibres
ponctuels a de fait beaucoup critiquer
le gradualisme phyletics qu'il appelait
le gradualisme phileétique c'est-à-dire
le ce qu'il appelait bah non en fait ce
qu'on appelle le gradualisme phytique et
ce que lui appelait le darwinisme du
coup donc il a beaucoup critiqué le
darwinisme dans le sens gradualisme
phytique
et de fait à chaque fois qu'il disait
non le gradualisme phileétique ça marche
pas ce sont les équilibres ponctués qui
marchent bien les créationsnistes ils
ont juste gardé leur partie de la phrase
ou il disait le gradualisme phileétique
ça marche pas vous voyez le il le dit
Docteur Stephen gigoul de gradualisme
phileétique ça marche pas donc là on
nous montre une réunion alors même en
admettant que ce que ces gens soient
effectivement des experts en théorie de
l'évolution mais honnêtement je
reconnais aucun nom pour l'instant donc
après c'est peut-être ma propre
ignorance je vais pas confondre ma
propre ignorance avec un fait avéré mais
même en admettant que tous ces gens sont
des experts en théorie de l'évolution vu
qu'on est sur un documentaire
créationniste on est en droit de se
demander est-ce que c'est ces phrases
n'ont pas été prises hors contexte
est-ce que ces gens ne se sont pas
réunies pour parler de effectivement de
moderniser la théorie de l'évolution
parce que quand même
à l'époque on avait cette émulsion avec
le gradualisme avec le gradualisme
phytique qui était remis en question par
Stephen gigould on avait cette émulsion
due à la découverte dans les années 80
je parle
dans les années 80 on a eu la théorie
d'Alvarez des des Alvarez qui a remis au
goût du jour le catastrophisme
encore une fois ça va de pair avec la
remise en question du gradualisme
phytique s'il y a d'un seul coup on
admet que les catastrophes peuvent jouer
un rôle majeur dans la dans l'évolution
des espèces faut remettre en question
les modèles on avait la génétique des
populations on qui était née on
commençait à cette époque à séquencer
des gènes donc on découvrait des choses
c'est par exemple à cette époque là que
les premières dans les années 80 que les
premières analyses génétiques ont
commencé à retrouver des groupements
chelous au sein des mammifères par
exemple les aphrotères pour ceux qui
connaissent ça ça vient des années 80
donc oui évidemment que la théorie de
l'évolution étant une théorie
scientifique elle se remet en question
contrairement au relie au reliquois au
reliqui
on continue il me semblait qu'il y avait
là quelque chose de bien plus
satisfaisant intellectuellement que ma
perspective précédente
[Musique]
on y repensant aujourd'hui je crois que
cela m'a motivé regardez de plus près
l'épreuve et à comprendre vers quoi
elles aboutissent
pour l'instant ce qui est dit il y a
rien de problématique
qui désirait désormais se pencher sur le
mystère fondamental de l'origine de la
vie
[Musique]
l'origine de la vie autre grande partie
du bingo créationniste
dramatisme ça aussi c'est un truc qui me
gave dans les documentaires les mises en
scène dramatiques
gros gros truc du bingo créationniste
effectivement l'origine de la vie la
théorie de l'évolution
n'explique pas à l'origine de la vie va
falloir vous le rentrer dans le crâne
les créationnisme mais genre bien la
théorie de l'évolution n'explique pas
l'origine de la vie elle explique
l'origine de la biodiversité depuis
que les mécanismes évolutifs genre la
sélection naturelle entre autres existe
or avant qu'il est enfin je veux dire
l'origine de la vie elle-même ne fait
pas partie des choses qui étaient sous
l'effet de ces mécanismes-là l'origine
de la vie elle-même obéit à des lois
strictement biochimiques pas biologiques
l'origine de la vie c'est une question
de chimiste ce n'est pas une question
d'évolutionniste
on est hors du champ de compétence de la
théorie de l'évolution avec l'origine de
la vie ça faut vous le rentrer mais
genre dans la tronche ça veut pas dire
que les évolutionnistes ont aucune idée
de comment la vie est apparue on a même
des idées très très nettes de comment la
vie est apparue on sait que des chaînes
d'acides aminés enfin on sait que les
acides aminés et même des chaînes
d'acides aminés peuvent se former dans
des météorites donc genre
l'environnement le plus pourrave au
monde
c'est dans le vide spatial c'est exposé
à tous les rayonnements il y a pas
d'atmosphère pour les protéger rien et
pourtant on a quand même des chaînes
d'acides aminés qui se forment dans les
météorites et ça j'en avais parlé dans
un Paléo news récent ce Paléo news là le
Paléo news numéro 32 non le papa de
Lucie n'est pas mort vous allez voir à
partir de 11 minutes TD je commence à
parler de Dieu la science et l'épreuve
et justement je vous montre les fameuses
preuves de ce qu'on appelle la biogénèse
donc la biogenèse qui est la théorie
scientifique de l'apparition de la vie à
partir de la non-vie à partir du minéral
enfin en l'occurrence pas du minéral
parce que le minéral c'est non
carbonique donc à partir du biochimique
et donc je vous montre des articles des
vraies revues scientifiques des vrais
articles de revues scientifique
prestigieuses comme nights en
communication où on vous dit qu'on
identifie une diversité ici en
l'occurrence c'est même pas des acides
aminés ici ce sont des acides nucléiques
donc les composants de l'ADN retrouver
dans des météorites donc on retrouve des
composants de l'ADN dans les météorites
et on retrouve ses composants de l'ADN
qui peuvent s'assembler ici c'est ce que
décrit cet article c'est composant de
l'ADN peuvent ensuite former des
polyribonucléotides donc de l'ADN ou de
l'ARN par exemple sur des roches
volcaniques les roches volcaniques
servent de catalyseur à
l'ADN et l'ARN aux chênes de
ribonucléides
donc en fait la le on n'a pas besoin de
la théorie de l'évolution jusque là
c'est de la biochimie de base aucun de
ces gens là n'est évolutionniste aucun
de ces gens là dans les dans les auteurs
de ces articles n'est un état biologiste
même ou un paléontologue ou n'importe
quoi donc il faut bien vous rentrez dans
la tête que il y a pas
c'est pas le domaine de la théorie de
l'évolution d'expliquer l'origine de la
vie mais évidemment les créationnistes
eux ça les arrange pas eux ce qu'ils
veulent c'est dire les évolutionnistes
n'y connaissent rien les évolutionnistes
ne peuvent pas expliquer ci ne peuvent
pas expliquer ça bah non on ne peut pas
expliquer ça parce que ce n'est pas
notre domaine ce n'est pas notre domaine
de compétences allez parler à un
biochimiste par contre là il vous
répondra
et ces arrêts sur image me font vraiment
une tronche donc je m'en vais voilà
mais ça ça fait partie du grand bingo
créationniste et de manière générale
d'ailleurs les créationnistes ont très
très peur du coup qu'on enlève à Dieu
c'est parce qu'évidemment il y a ça
aussi derrière le créationnisme le
créationnisme il est pas il est pas
innocent il a il a un but ce
créationniste et se créationnisme en
particulier là quand on est sur du
créationnisme nord-américain bas de
plafond c'est évidemment de promouvoir
la religion il y a certains
créationnistes qui vont qui vont plutôt
essayer de promouvoir leurs idées
ésotériques sur l'origine extraterrestre
de la vie
mais bon la plupart des créationsnistes
c'est quand même pour promouvoir leur
religion qu'elle soit chrétienne
musulmane je sais pas je suis pas très
au courant des créationsnisme Juifs et
bouddhistes mais il y a pas de raison
qu'ils n'existent pas même s'ils sont
moins même s'ils ont beaucoup moins de
publicités soyons tout à fait honnêtes
mais c'est créationnisme ils ont un but
contrairement à la théorie de
l'évolution la théorie de l'évolution
n'a pas d'autre but d'exister que
elle-même que la compréhension du de
l'origine de la biodiversité il y a pas
d'agenda politique derrière la théorie
de l'évolution même si c'est ce qu'on va
essayer de vous faire croire dans ce
reportage j'en suis sûr dans ce
documentaire pardon à chaque fois je dis
reportage donc on va essayer de vous
faire croire qu'il y a un agenda
politique il y en a pas il y en a pas
l'argent et le pouvoir
les chercheurs ils ont de l'argent et du
pouvoir lol
et donc oui la religion
est la motivation
ultime de tous ses créationsnismes c'est
on va essayer de redonner son pouvoir
créateur à Dieu finalement parce que la
théorie de l'évolution elle dit quand
même que la Genèse bah c'est caca ça
c'est pas produit bon il y a encore des
gens pourquoi la Genèse littéralement
visiblement on est en 2022 et il y a
encore des gens pour lire le récit de la
Genèse en 6 jours rien d'autre
il a tout créé il y a encore des gens
pour croire ça littéralement il y a
encore des gens pour croire que le
premier être humain a été sculpté à
partir de la glaise et encore se [ __ ]
de la gueule des évolutionnistes quand
on parle de la biogenèse ça c'est ça moi
je trouve ça formidable
moi je trouve ça
parfait c'est les mecs ils regardent la
biogénèse il se marre mais à côté de ça
ils vont croire littéralement que
l'homme a été sculpté dans la glaise
l'homme a pas la femme d'ailleurs la
femme elle a été clonée avec une côte de
l'homme
bref bref donc
et puis vous avez l'intelligence design
avec lequel je n'aurai aucun problème le
l'intelligent design ou dessin
intelligent en français qui est donc non
on croit pas littéralement le récit de
la Genèse donc c'est quand même un
progrès sur le créationnisme cru c'est
un petit progrès et cette ce dessin
intelligent lui il postule que oui
l'évolution à Dieu mais c'est
l'évolution a lieu mais c'est Dieu qui
pousse les espèces à évoluer
généralement ça s'accompagne d'un
finalisme assez outrageant le summum de
ce finalisme étant donc le finalisme
c'est quand vous dites le nez le nez
existe pour porter les lunettes c'est du
finalisme ça
c'est de vous donner un but à quelque
chose qui n'a pas de but
et donc le sommet de se finalise c'est
de dire que finalement toutes les
espèces évoluent vers l'homme parce que
enfin que l'évolution a eu lieu que pour
que l'homme apparaisse encore une fois
l'homme l'homme avec un grand H sont
peut-être un peu plus modérés non
l'humain est donc au sommet de
l'évolution puisque le choisit de Dieu
évidemment et je n'aurai donc pas de
problème avec l'intelligente design si
l'intelligente design ne se faisait pas
ne se travestissez pas en théorie
scientifique je voulais si c'était juste
une opinion comme ça bon on s'en fout je
veux dire mais non ils essayent de
s'institut de s'institutionnaliser en
sciences c'est tenant du dessin
intelligent
et là j'ai un problème là j'ai un
problème parce que basiquement j'ai une
théorie de l'évolution qui est une
voiture et qui roule très bien toute
seule
voilà j'en connais les rouages je sais
comment elle marche je sais que je sais
que si je la démarre elle va rouler tout
droit et donc les tonneaux de
l'intelligence design eux ils croient en
la sainte roue de vélo et ils veulent
absolument inclure une roue de vélo dans
ma bagnole qui roule déjà très bien
toute seule
et ils arrivent pas à comprendre c'est
étonnant de l'intelligence design et les
créationsnistes en général donc la roue
de vélo c'est Dieu évidemment donc la
sainte roue de vélo là Dieu ils essaient
d'inclure ça dans ma bagnole et ils
arrivent pas à comprendre pourquoi on
leur dit mais non va explique-moi au
moins pourquoi tu veux ajouter une roue
de vélo et eux tout ce qu'il dit c'est
ben non mais la roue de vélo elle est là
il faut la mettre quelque part c'est la
sainte roue de vélo tu peux pas faire
100 bah oui mais
c'est un trou de vélo je veux dire on en
a pas besoin la voiture elle roule très
bien toute seule la théorie de
l'évolution elle marche très bien sans
qu'on inclut Dieu dedans mais non ils
tiennent absolument à ce que leur sainte
roue de vélo qu'il faut absolument
inclure quel que soit la raison il y en
a pas des raisons mais il faut
absolument l'inclure il va absolument
qu'elle fasse partie de la voiture sans
expliquer pourquoi parce que pour eux
c'est juste pas envisageable de pas
avoir la sainte roue de vélo dans la
voiture ou que ce soit d'ailleurs la
sainte roue de vélo elle va partout dans
la cuisine dans la salle à manger
c'est le Willy Waller tu vois il faut le
mettre partout le dans les toilettes
dans la dans la 14 Willy
dans les toilettes dans l'entrée dans le
14 12 dans la cuisine enfin bref
juste pas à comprendre que si tu veux
inclure cette route vélo dans la voiture
va falloir que tu nous expliques au
moins pourquoi
et leurs explications sont toujours
pétées
alors qu'on en a pour 1h de documentaire
c'est horrible vous le sentez qu'on va
souffrir vous le sentez que ça va être
long vous le sentez que vous allez
perdre votre journée à m'écouter vous le
sentez que je suis en train de perdre ma
journée à regarder ça sérieusement
ah oui et puis évidemment un cow-boy un
cow-boy ça manquait au générique
déchiffrer les mystères de la vie on
s'arrêtera sur on s'arrêtera quand même
sur le fait que le documentaire
s'appelle déchiffrer les mystères de la
vie et que pour une raison que j'ignore
partout il s'appelle l'effondrement de
la théorie de l'évolution
c'est à dire que les mecs qui le
repartent n'ont même pas pris le temps
de remettre le bon le bon titre c'est
ouf c'est ouf
il l'ont même pas regardé je suis sur un
ce documentaire ils savent que c'est un
documentaire créationniste et du coup il
leur partage comme ça
[Musique]
l'incroyable diversité et la complexité
la notion de complexité le bingo
continue la notion de complexité la vis
est trop complexe c'est trop c'est trop
beau c'est trop magique l'ADN c'est trop
compliqué ça peut pas apparaître tout
seul je viens de vous parler de l'ADN je
viens de vous le dire je viens de vous
montrer les sources vous pouvez aller
voir les sources sont en description ici
les poly ribonucléides enfin nuclé les
poly ribeauducléotides donc les
assemblages de nucléotides tels que
l'ADN et la RN peuvent apparaître tout
seul
sans que la vie soit là ça c'est
important parce que dans une vision
créationniste c'est juste pas possible
que des polyribonucléotides apparaissent
tout seul pour rien ça il faut bien vous
le rentrer dans le crâne une vision
créationniste par définition c'est la
création faut que ça ait un but c'est un
forcément un but il y a un cahier des
charges si vous avez une vision
créationniste du monde l'existence de
polyribonucléotide d'assemblage de
d'assemblage de nucléotides et
d'assemblage aussi de d'acide aminés qui
existent pour rien pas pour le vivant
ça devrait vous choquer parce que c'est
pas normal ces trucs là n'existent que
pour le vivant
je rappelle par ailleurs qu'il existe
400 acides aminés on en utilise que 20
dans le 21 dans le vivant
il y a quand même beaucoup d'acides
aminés qui servent à que dalle pour le
vivant mais bon je
enfin des acides aminés qui sont
réellement utilisés dans les protéines
il y en a que 21 sur les 400 qui
existent ça vous laisse penseur sur
l'idée que les acides aminés auraient
été créés
aurait été créé spécialement pour la vie
par une intelligence supérieure bref
donc la complexité et la complexité ça a
fait c'est quelque chose que les
créationnistes encore une fois aiment
beaucoup c'est malheureusement un truc
que les évolutionnistes utilisent encore
de trop moi y compris je suis coupable
aussi d'utiliser le mot complexité mais
la complexité c'est un truc qui est
tellement vague en fait tout le monde
croit voir ce que ça veut dire et en
même temps personne ne sait réellement
ce que ça veut dire ça fait partie de
ces concepts un peu un peu fourre-tout
un peu flou la complexité le problème
c'est que c'est une question de point de
vue c'est à dire que si je vous montre
une horloge et un caillou
vous allez dire quoi bah que l'horloge
est plus complexe évidemment
sauf que le caillou chimiquement il a
plus de composants chimiques il y a plus
d'atomes différents dans un caillou que
dans une horloge une horloge elle est
faite d'acier enfin d'un métal
quelconque d'un métal quelconque qui
peut être un alliage ou pas on s'en fout
mais l'horloge quoi qu'il arrive
chimiquement elle est simple comparée
comparé à la composition chimique d'un
granite le granite et hautement plus
complexe dans sa structure chimique que
neylorloge
donc c'est juste une question de point
de vue la complexité donc à partir du
moment où on commence à vous beurrer la
nouille avec de la complexité il faut
vous méfier
faut vous méfier parce que la complexité
et on en avait fait encore une fois une
vidéo où on explique éminemment pourquoi
il faut se méfier de la notion de
complexité en tractation
complexité et complot non pas complot
par pitié complexité on va déjà avoir
suffisamment de complots donc la
complexité avec Scarlett Johansson sur
la miniature parce que quand on est des
bouffes ou on l'est pas et où justement
vous explique pendant à peu près 20
minutes pourquoi que la complexité que
c'est trop nul pourquoi que ça sert à
rien de discuter complexité avec un
créationniste
le bazar de la nécessité de force
naturelle non dirigées ou les autres
choses le hasard le hasard a encore un
élément un élément récurrent c'est ça
fait trois minutes ça fait trois minutes
et le bingo il fait Bing Bing Bing Bing
Bing croire que la j'ai dit tout à
l'heure que croire que l'évolution c'est
que la sélection naturelle mais alors là
c'est pire c'est croire que l'évolution
c'est que le hasard
évidemment on va vous dire mais non mais
c'est trop complexe pour être le hasard
bah oui mais on n'a jamais aucun
évolutionniste n'a jamais dit que
l'évolution c'était le hasard c'est je
comprends pas j'ai toujours pas compris
d'où ça venait ça aucun évolutionniste
n'a jamais dit que l'évolution c'était
le hasard la sélection naturelle
sélection naturelle
il y a pas il y a aucune ambiguïté sur
ce que le mot sélection naturelle veut
dire il y a pas de hasard dans un
phénomène de sélection
je comprends même pas qu'on est encore à
expliquer ça
c'est dans leurs rêves dans leur rêve en
fait c'est un homme de paille c'est ce
qu'on sait c'est exactement typiquement
ce qu'on appelle un homme de paille
mettre le hasard au centre de mécanisme
évolutif c'est juste un mensonge et
honté on crée un homme de paille on crée
à cet épouvantail du hasard en disant
regardez c'est ça la théorie de
l'évolution bah non c'est pas ça la
théorie de l'évolution la théorie de
l'évolution ça a toujours été
descendance avec modification
naturelle la descendance avec
modification bon bah c'est ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui les mutations mais à
l'époque de Darwin parce que j'ai dit
toujours avant donc toujours c'est
depuis Darwin donc depuis Darwin il y a
la descendance avec modification qui
crée de la diversité
au pif effectivement c'est la
descendance avec modification on ne
ressemble pas à nos parents basiquement
à part si vous êtes une bactérie qui se
reproduit par clonage parmiose mais
sinon vous ne ressemblez pas à vos
parents donc ça crée de la diversité et
la sélection naturelle dans cette
diversité
des gros coup de hache dans cette
diversité en ne permettant la
reproduction que de certains individus
les individus qui dans un environnement
donné vont avoir un avantage donné
c'est pas du hasard ça ce mouvement de
taille là c'est l'opposé du hasard ça
donne une direction la sélection
naturelle donne une direction à
l'évolution donc encore le bingo
créationniste 3 minutes on a déjà coché
combien de cases 6
je crois pas honnêtement c'est je crois
que c'est mon boss final je pense pas
que je vais tenir jusqu'au bout je pense
honnêtement que je vais abandonner
le mystère de l'origine de la vie étant
donné qu'ils avaient tous des doutes
importants concernant les idées
évolutionnistes largement répandus
parmi eux le biochimiste Michael Biffy
se demander comment des processus
naturels avaient pu donner lieu aux
structures très élaborées présentes dans
les cellules vivantes digne canyon
biologiste évolutionniste ne consiste
expliquer les origines de la vie sur
Terre elle peut je vous ai montré les
articles
c'est trop marrant parce que les mecs
ils sont là en mode tu vois tellement le
cameraman qui leur a dit vas-y prends
une pause dramatique pour la pour la
c'est pastétique c'est pas c'est
d'autant plus pathétique que j'ai eu
l'occasion de tourner pour des
documentaires et effectivement on te
demande de regarder vers l'horizon en
prenant une pause dramatique pendant à
peu près une demi-heure
et c'est horrible c'est horrible comme
traitement
c'est scientifique et philosophes
commencèrent à formuler une alternative
à la théorie centrale de la biologie
moderne une théorie qui a pris naissance
dans l'esprit du naturaliste anglais
Charles Darwin quand est-ce qu'on va
nous dire qu'il était alcoolique Charles
Darwin
en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'Angleterre à bord de la chaise beagle
il fit le tour de l'Amérique du Sud puis
remonta au nord dans l'océan Pacifique
vers les îles volcaniques des Galapagos
[Musique]
sur cet archipel des aires à 965 km des
côtes c'est équatoriennes Charles Darwin
rencontra une grande variété d'oiseaux
de reptiles et de mammifères tel qu'il
en avait jamais vu auparavant
[Applaudissements]
il étudier les plantes et les animaux
pris des notes détaillés et récolta des
spécimens puis il plia bagage pour ne
jamais revenir
[Musique]
25 ans s'écoulèrent pendant lesquelles
il développa une théorie sur l'origine
des diverses formes de la vie sur Terre
en 1859 Darwin publié un ouvrage
intitulé
space dans l'impact sur la science et
par la suite sur toute la culture
occidentale fut très importante
parmi nous cherchez à montrer que la vie
était le produit de force naturelle
aléatoire
[Musique]
et un processus
donc non pas l'aléatoire
la grande je veux dire le titre le titre
de L'Origine des espèces c'est pas juste
de L'Origine des espèces c'est de
L'Origine des espèces par le moyen de la
sélection naturelle donc bref l'origine
des espèces par les moyens de la
sélection naturelle la préservation des
des sous-espèces des populations
privilégiées dans la lutte pour la vie
c'est c'est
ça ça parle tout seul je veux dire ça il
y a pas le mot aléatoire il y a pas le
mot hasard il y a pas le mot rien du
tout
tout est là dans le titre c'est à dire
que ces gros Charlots de créationnistes
de mes deux
ne lisent pas le titre
de de l'origine des espacés ils ont
tellement pas lu l'origine des espèces
que même le titre ils l'ont pas lu
il y a des gens des millions de
personnes qui ont vu ce documentaire on
va peut-être pas des millions mais des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
l'ont vu et s'ils cherchent dans les
commentaires
ça je suis sûr qu'on va trouver des gens
qui disent ah là là c'est vraiment c'est
tellement vrai bah non c'est un énorme
mensonge mais énormément songe
ah enfin
on arrête de nous parler d'aller à toi
non comme Platon Newton au Kepler
considérait le monde comme le produit
d'une certaine conception d'un certain
plan
voilà c'est là le moment où la sélection
naturelle va devenir le seul et unique
mécanisme évolutif c'est maintenant que
ça vient
intéressant
que dans un documentaire créationniste
la sélection naturelle soit qualifiée de
mécanismes plausible 6 minutes 32 6
minutes 32 vous venez peut-être
d'entendre la chaux la seule chose
intelligente de ce documentaire
pour comprendre comment s'opère la
sélection
sont un exemple donc de sélection
naturelle qui est classique on va dire
dans le retrouve dans tous les livres
d'écoles je suis d'accord mais pas son
Darwin n'ont pas été étudiés par Darwin
voilà je tenais à préciser cette petite
petit élément d'histoire des sciences
sachez que les pinsons de Darwin n'ont
pas été étudiés par Darwin et sachez
aussi d'ailleurs que les pinsons de
Darwin sont toujours l'objet d'études
très très très approfondie quant à
comment quand tu as essayé de retracer
leur évolution parce que les personnes
Darwin on n'a pas vraiment de fossiles
les îles des Galapagos c'est pas
exactement le coin le plus facile et
faire du monde sont des petits
îlots c'est volcaniques c'est pas très
c'est pas il y a pas la surface qu'il
faut pour préserver des beaux fossiles
donc tout ce qu'on a sur les pinsons de
Darwin c'est essentiellement de la de
des analyses génétiques qui ont
d'ailleurs confirmé les études
précédentes sur la morphologie et on a
des et donc on a des études
morphologiques des espèces modernes donc
il faut bien je sais pas ce qu'ils vont
dire après comme connerie sur les
pinsons de Darwin mais sachez que s'ils
se mettent à parler de fossiles on va
rigoler
en Angleterre avec neuf espèces
différentes de ces oiseaux
mais c'est pas lui qui les a étudié
[Musique]
un exemple souvent cité et celui des
pinsons mangeurs de graines
[Musique]
parce qu'avec les passons de Darwin
c'est qu'on a effectivement des
qu'on a effectivement avec les pinsons
de Darwin un exemple assez flagrant de
comment on est passé de un truc
ancestral hypothétique
à plein d'adaptations à des niches
écologiques différentes ça qu'on voit
c'est ça qui a d'intéressant avec les
pinsons ce qui faut parce que c'est
pareil ils oublient de vous rappeler
pourquoi c'est intéressant c'est un son
ce qui a d'intéressant avec ces pinsons
c'est qu'en fait ils se sont des espèces
différentes aujourd'hui mais qui sont si
peu différents de cet ancêtre en commun
que finalement c'est pas dur d'imaginer
à quoi cet ancêtre en commun devait
ressembler on imagine bien un ancêtre en
commun non spécialisé arriver sur les
îles et comment le bec s'est adapté à
manger si manger ça manger ça manger ça
donc c'est c'est ça qui est intéressant
avec les pinsons c'est qu'on arrive en
fait sans trop d'imagination à
reconstituer l'ancêtre en commun
ça se voit en fait ça c'est assez visuel
comme exemple c'est ça qui est bien avec
les pinsons
ça on vous expliquera pas dans un
documentaire créationniste
les oiseaux
sèches les seules graines disponibles
sont enveloppées dans des coquilles très
résistantes elles sont là depuis l'année
précédente dans ces circonstances seuls
les oiseaux avec l'âge et la serré
peuvent briser ses coquilles et
s'alimenter ça c'est exactement ça ce
qu'il faut en fait ce qu'il faut c'est
opposer c'est peut-être dans ce qui
manque dans mon explication précédente
c'est ce qu'il faut opposer c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on attend
d'une création
qu'elle soit divine ou extraterrestre
mais bon divine est extraterrestre de
toute façon puisque Dieu n'est pas
terrestre donc Dieu est extraterrestre
par définition mais qu'est-ce qu'on
attend d'une création en fait qu'est-ce
qu'on attend d'une création on attend
d'une création qu'elle obéisse donc un
call obéissent
à une sorte de cahier des charges donc
le cahier des charges c'est
cette espèce je la place là et elle doit
survivre dans tel environnement vous
voyez j'ai créé cette espèce pour la
placer dans cet environnement pour
qu'elle y survivre et se reproduisent
donc on attend ça d'une création
mais qu'est-ce qu'on attend pas d'une
création bah c'est une ressemblance en
fait entre les différentes espèces c'est
à dire pourquoi pourquoi des espèces
placées sur différentes îles des
Galapagos
devrait se ressembler
moi je le demande je le demande à si
vous êtes créationniste et que vous êtes
déjà outrage de des propos que je tiens
jusqu'à présent je vous demande pourquoi
est-ce que des espèces placées sur
différentes îles des Galapagos seraient
toutes
identifiable comme des pinsons Darwin
c'est que ce documentaire va évidemment
se focaliser sur invalider la théorie de
l'évolution toi par point mais va jamais
vous fournir une explication sur
pourquoi est-ce qu'il devrait en être
autrement vous voyez ce que je veux dire
ça on va pas vous dire on va pas
seulement vous dire on va seulement se
contenter de vous dire non mais la
théorie de l'évolution elle explique pas
bien tu vois mais on va jamais vous dire
pourquoi ça devrait être autrement bah
en l'occurrence si on s'attend à une
création ou même à un dessin intelligent
pourquoi est-ce que ces pinsons
appartiendraient à la même espèce
peut-être avec le dessin intelligent on
peut l'expliquer un peu
mais par contre une création pourquoi
est-ce que c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
pas directement mis un perroquet avec un
gros bec et pourquoi est-ce que de
l'autre côté on n'a pas mis directement
je sais pas moi un machin avec un petit
bec à une autre espèce d'oiseau avec un
petit bec sachant que ces espèces
existent par ailleurs voyez pourquoi
recréer des nouveaux une nouvelle espèce
alors qu'on a déjà des espèces agrobés
qui auraient très bien fait l'affaire
ailleurs pourquoi est-ce qu'elles ont
pas été placés là
cette cette distribution
doit être expliquée et elle s'explique
très bien avec la théorie de l'évolution
un ancêtre en commun est arrivé et s'est
adapté elle ne s'explique pas du tout
avec une création ça on ne peut pas
expliquer avec une création pourquoi
est-ce que on aurait
pour une raison qu'on ignore des pinsons
ils sont tous identifiables comme
appartenant à la même famille mais avec
des spécialisations différentes pourquoi
est-ce que tout pourquoi est-ce que dans
un contexte de création tout se
passerait comme si ils avaient évolué
ce que Dieu essaye de nous faire croire
que l'évolution existe alors qu'elle
n'existe pas c'est pourquoi et pourquoi
tu vois ce que je veux dire parce que
Dieu il nous aime normalement tout cas
moi c'est ce qu'on m'a appris Dieu
normalement il nous aime il va pas
essayer de nous piéger
et puis Dieu il sait déjà de toute façon
si on va être si on est piable ou pas il
y a ça aussi Dieu Il est Omniscient il
sait tout donc Dieu va pas essayer de te
piéger en sachant très bien que tu vas
tomber dans le panneau
si il t'aime
si Dieu nous aime et qui veut pas qu'on
aille en enfer il va pas essayer de te
piéger en sachant que tu vas tomber dans
le panneau
et si il sait déjà que tu vas pas tomber
dans le panneau parce qu'il est
omniscient si c'est déjà que tu vas pas
tomber dans le panneau pourquoi essaie
de le piéger
point d'interrogation
[Musique]
je vous laisse réfléchir à ce concept là
pourquoi Dieu voudrait que tu crois en
l'évolution basiquement pourquoi Dieu a
placé des fossiles dans une séquence
particulière pour qu'on voit d'une part
qu'on commence par les poissons qu'on va
ensuite aux amphibiens qu'on va ensuite
au reptiles qu'on va ensuite au
mammifères pourquoi Dieu a placé les
fossiles dans le registre fossile de
telle sorte qui est moins de diversité
au début et plus de diversité vers la
fin donc l'augmentation de la diversité
pas régulière parce qu'il y a des
extinctions de masse au milieu mais il y
a une augmentation de la diversité
enregistrée dans le registre fossile
pourquoi Dieu aurait fait ça si ce n'est
pas pour toi de croire la théorie de
l'évolution et pourquoi moi en tant
qu'être humain devrais-je me croire plus
intelligent que Dieu
est-ce que c'est vraiment aimer Dieu que
de me croire plus intelligent que lui en
disant je vois bien ce que tu as fait là
dans le registre fossile Dieu je vois
bien ce que tu as fait avec tes pinsons
de Darwin Dieu mais
mais je vais pas tomber dans le panneau
de quel droit et de quel droit
devrais-je me sentir plus intelligent
que ça
tellement de questions c'est à ça que
sert les apologies chrétiens qui ont
fait cette vidéo c'est c'est à trouver
des excuses pour ces réponses là enfin
pour ces questions là
survivent parce qu'ils peuvent se
procurer à manger contrairement aux
autres volatiles leur large bec leur
offre ce que les biologistes appellent
aujourd'hui un avantage fonctionnel
un petit Deck et là se meurt de faim
parce qu'ils ne peuvent accéder à la
nourriture
si la sécheresse perdure ces conditions
environnementales entraînent des
changements dans la population des
pinsons
déclare son transmis aux générations
suivantes parce qu'ils permettent à ses
oiseaux de
Sion la sélection naturelle était une
idée très attrayante les variations
physiques avantageuses seraient héritée
au fil des générations à travers ce
processus les populations seraient
modifiées et au fil du temps les
organismes fondamentalement différents
apparaîtrait sans qu'aucune forme
d'intelligence ne guide ce processus
bonne explication de la sélection
naturelle
[Musique]
un auteurs produisait des changements
en fait que le même processus existait
par l'état naturel
la sélection naturelle conception sans
la présence d'un concepteur il n'était
plus nécessaire d'évoquer une cause
intelligence face à la complexité de la
vie résultat la sélection naturelle
venait se substituer au concepteur et
c'est ça qui fait peur au créationnistes
aujourd'hui la science et le monde c'est
qu'on enlève à Dieu sans pouvoir
créateur
la théorie de l'évolution n'invalide pas
l'existence de Dieu jamais à aucun
moment à la limite elle tout au plus
elle invalide la capacité de Dieu à
enfin la nécessité de faire intervenir
Dieu pour comprendre l'origine de la
biodiversité même pas comme je l'ai dit
l'origine de la vie puisque ce n'est pas
la théorie de l'évolution qui explique
l'origine de la vie
c'est donc une autre théorie qui
s'appelle la biogenèse qui n'est pas une
théorie de biologie évolutive c'est une
théorie biochimique donc il y a pas
besoin de de Dieu pour expliquer
l'origine de la biodiversité donc ça
invalide l'intervention de Dieu dans
l'origine de la biodiversité moderne
mais en aucun cas ça n'a valide
l'existence de Dieu mais je sais pas
pourquoi en fait les créationsnistes ont
très très peur que les de la théorie de
l'évolution parce que Dieu n'est plus
responsable de la de l'origine de du de
la diversité du vivant
et je sais pas pourquoi ça c'est plus
effrayant que quand on dit que Dieu
n'est pas responsable de la gravité et
je sais pas pourquoi ça c'est plus
effrayant que de dire que c'est Dieu qui
que c'est votre cerveau qui est
responsable de votre personnalité et pas
l'âme que Dieu a insufflé dans votre
corps
je comprends pas pourquoi en fait c'est
je comprends pas pourquoi le front le
front de bataille du
de la religion contre la science se
trouve précisément enfin se trouve en
majeure partie on va dire sur le front
de la théorie de l'évolution c'est
admettant qui est réellement une
bataille entre la science et la religion
évidemment
ce qui selon moi est une absurdité et je
suis pas le seul à le penser mais pour
moi il y a la science il y a la religion
et il y a un mur de Berlin entre les
deux avec des miradors un champ de mine
et il devrait jamais se toucher mais
bref le
le front de bataille puisqu'il existe on
peut pas nier son existence je veux dire
ça c'est un ce documentaire est une arme
utilisée dans cette bataille donc cette
bataille existe on peut pas nier son
existence et je ne comprends pas
pourquoi ce front de bataille se trouve
essentiellement sur la théorie de
l'évolution il y en a d'autres je suis
d'accord mais curieusement
ça a été beaucoup plus acceptable de la
proposition votre personnalité vient de
votre cerveau
et beaucoup plus accepté
ou en tout cas est beaucoup moins sujet
à controverse que la proposition les
espèces ont évoluées et je comprends pas
pourquoi
j'imagine que c'est parce que l'âme le
concept Dam est tellement intangible est
tellement flexible que de toute façon ça
sert à rien je veux dire c'est comme
essayer de se battre dans un bol de
semoule ça sert à rien ça vous allez
vous épuiser très rapidement pour pas
grand pour pas beaucoup de résultats
mais mais je comprends pas
en tout cas les créationnistes sont très
peur de la théorie de l'évolution alors
que la théorie de l'évolution ne valide
pas les invalide absolument pas
l'existence de Dieu
je sais c'est intéressant de de plonger
dans la psyché d'un créationniste en
regardant ce documentaire vous voyez en
fait que en fonction des pics qui
lancent à la théorie de l'évolution vous
voyez ce qui leur fait peur ce qui leur
fait peur c'est l'aléatoire
ce qui n'est pas un mécanisme de la
théorie de l'évolution enfin ce qui
n'est pas le seul et unique mécanisme de
la théorie de l'évolution il intervient
beaucoup dans la dérive génétique par
exemple mais la dérive génétique n'est
qu'un des multiples mécanismes et
l'opposé en fait de la sélection
naturelle d'ailleurs
le ce qui leur fait peur c'est la donc
l'absence de créateur mais la théorie de
l'évolution n'applique pas l'absence
d'un créateur c'est juste que la théorie
de l'évolution si vous la prenez tout
seul sans la biogenèse
elle explique pas elle vous dit rien à
propos du créateur absolument rien c'est
la biogenèse votre problème donc
j'imagine que là on va s'orienter vers
la biogénèse
malgré cette large acceptation un nombre
croissant de scientifiques et de savons
y compris ceux de pas avoir une
remettent en question des aspects
importants du darwinisme non c'est faux
c'est faux un nombre croissant de
savants non c'est faux le nombre
le nombre de savants qui acceptait qui
acceptait la qui accepte la théorie de
l'évolution aujourd'hui et bien
supérieur enfin le nombre pas le nombre
mais la proportion de savant qui accepte
la théorie de l'évolution aujourd'hui et
bien plus grand que la proportion qu'il
y avait à l'époque de Darwin par
définition mais même un peu après je
veux dire
il y avait beaucoup de savants sorichard
Owens le premier temps
donc ça Richard Owen le premier a remis
en question contemporaine Darwin a remis
en question là le darwinisme il y avait
des figures et sœurs Richard Owen
c'était pas Jul claudeau si vous
connaissez pas sur Richard Owen Richard
Owens c'est l'équivalent anglais de
Cuvier quoi c'est l'autorité
scientifique suprême en matière de
biologie de son époque
et il remettait en question ouvertement
la théorie de l'évolution sans aucun
problème et ça c'est peu de temps après
Charles Darwin le nombre de
scientifiques de manière générale est
allée croissants depuis l'époque de
Charles Darwin et le nombre de ses
scientifiques qui ont remis en question
la validité de la théorie de l'évolution
est allé décroissant définitivement donc
ça c'est des ça c'est une énorme
connerie il y a pas un nombre de plus en
plus grande scientifiques qui remettent
en question et après on peut se poser la
question de la validité de l'opinion de
ces scientifiques dans une certaine dans
la mesure où si vous avez que des
ingénieurs des physiciens et des enfin
des gens qui n'ont aucune compétence en
biologie
bah ils peuvent bien remettre en
question la théorie de l'évolution au
moins autant que moi paléontologue je
peux remettre en question la physique
quantique
si demain je vous dis la physique
quantique c'est des conneries bah j'ose
espérer que vous allez me remettre à ma
place en disant qu'il connaît rien ta
gueule
parce que c'est tout ce que je mérite en
finale si demain j'affirme que que faire
une opération à cœur ouvert ça se fait
ça se fait facilement sans les mains
voilà je peux vous faire une opération
coeur ouvert avec les dents remettant en
question 200 ans de pratique de de la
chirurgie
euh pareil tout ce que je mérite c'est
un ta gueule et retourne faire retourne
avec tes cailloux ou quoi
d'ailleurs et peut-être éviter de me
remettre des cailloux dans les mains si
je prétends si je prétends pouvoir
opérer à cœur ouvert avec les dents
c'est probablement qu'à un moment qui a
un endroit où il y a un fusible qui a
grillé bref
on continue
de la sélection naturelle et le rôle
qu'il exaçait dans les explications
d'ordre biologique
la sélection naturelle est un processus
bien réel qui permet d'expliquer
certaines variations limitées un petit
échec et nous en avons beaucoup
d'exemples
clairement aux espérances de Darwin elle
ne suffit pas à expliquer la profonde
voilà la nouveau nouvelle case du bingo
coché microévolution contre
macroévolution la sélection naturelle
est un phénomène dont ils acceptent
l'existence mais elle n'est pas capable
de produire de la macroévolution elle va
produire que de la microévolution c'est
à dire des petites adaptations locales
mais jamais des grosses adaptations
et ce à quoi ma réponse est toujours et
a toujours été en vertu de quoi
parce que ça c'est quand même balèze
en vertu de quoi est-ce que accumuler
des grains de sable ne va pas
lentement mais sûrement finir par former
une dune je ne comprends pas je
l'accumulation de grains de sable une
dune est une accumulation de grains de
sable donc en vertu de quoi ces gens se
permettent de dire l'accumulation de
grains de sable ne va pas finir par
créer une dune je je c'est ça c'est ils
vont regarder votre votre tas de sable
et même s'il fait 4 mètres de haut et
est plus grand que la dune du Pilat ils
vont regarder votre tas de sable et ils
vont vous dire non ça c'est que un tas
de sable c'est pas une dune
vous voyez et donc on rentre dans cette
espèce d'essentialisme en fait si vous
voyez c'est que pour eux le concept
d'espèces est immuable
et de fait on atteint jamais le niveau
où on peut appeler quelque chose deux
espèces différentes la macroévolution
la définition de macroévolution c'est le
moment où il y a spéciation à partir du
moment où vous avez spéciation vous avez
séparation d'espèces vous avez
macroévolution et pour eux pour eux il y
a jamais spécial
et ça je comprends pas
ça je comprends pas parce que spéciation
des exemples de spécialisation on en a
plein alors d'une ils vont jouer ces
créationsnistes ils vont jouer
énormément sur le flou artistique qu'il
y a sur la définition d'espèce puisque
je rappelle qu'il existe une bonne
quinzaine de définition au concept
d'espèces les trois principales étant
l'espèce morphologique l'espèce
génétique l'espèce biologique
des exemples d'espèces de spéciation
biologiques on en a plein la spéciation
biologique c'est quand deux individus de
deux populations
ne peuvent plus se reproduire en fait
vous avez une population elle s'est
séparée en deux et ensuite quand vous
regroupez ces deux populations en fait
les individus des deux populations
n'arrivent plus à se reproduire entre
eux et ça vous en avez plein des
exemples comme ça votre Chihuahua est
incapable de se reproduire avec un
doberman
vous allez finir avec un chihuahua
brochette
ou avec un chihuahua qui s'astique sur
le qui ça ou un chihuahua mâle qui
s'astique sur le la guibole de votre
doberman femelle mais en aucun cas un
chihuahua ne peut naturellement se
reproduire avec un doberman le chihuahua
et le doberman sont physiquement
incompatibles ils sont déjà deux espèces
différentes
alors oui je sais ça vous fait chier ça
va vous faire chier
on dit que le chihuahua et le doberman
sont deux espèces différentes mais tout
ce que je crois savoir et oui bah oui
tout ce que tu crois savoir est basé sur
des définitions et ces définitions
elles sont arbitraires comme toutes les
définitions et il faut ne pas être
essentialiste il ne faut pas croire que
cette définition
valent quelque chose au-delà de ce
pourquoi elles sont utiles à un être
humain
ce sont des définitions formulées par
les êtres humains pour les êtres humains
pour nous aider à comprendre la nature
une espèce c'est un concept purement
humain ça n'existe pas une espèce
c'est un concept humain le on a décrété
que si vous deux enfin les gens qui ont
défini l'espèce biologique cette
définition de la non de la non
compatibilité dans la nature
les gens qui ont défini l'espèce
biologique on dit on décrétait que si
deux individus sont incapables de
produire
une descendance fertile donc c'est pour
ça que le Lion et le tigre qui
produisent le ligre sont aussi
considérés comme deux espèces
différentes parce que le ligre lui-même
infertile donc si deux individus sont
incapables de produire indécendant
fertile alors ces deux individus
appartiennent à des espèces différentes
ça n'a ça ne veut rien dire
biologiquement
ça ne veut absolument rien dire
biologiquement parlant ça a l'air de
vouloir dire quelque chose
biologiquement parlant mais dans le cas
du chien c'est assez évident que le
doberman et le chihuahua
relâchez dans la nature ne se
reproduiront pas entre eux alors de
proche vous allez me dire oui mais de
proche en proche ils vont être
compatibles bah oui de prochains proches
ouais ce faut imaginer une série
d'événements ou un doberman va se
reproduire avec un truc légèrement plus
petit légèrement plus petit légèrement
plus petit jusqu'à atteindre le jusqu'à
ce que les gènes du doberman 50
générations plus tard atteignent des
gènes de chihuahua
oui en théorie c'est possible n'empêche
qu'en pratique le doberman n'empêche
qu'en pratique dans une dans un cadre
naturel sans intervention anthropique le
doberman et le chihuahua ne se
reproduisent pas
donc s'ils sont incapables si vous les
mettez dans la même boîte et que il en
ressort pas d'obiwa ou un Chiwa man bah
c'est pas la même espèce
voilà donc ça c'est la définition
biologique par contre la définition
génétique le doberman et chihuahua sont
toujours de la même espèce leur gêne
sont très similaires parce que la
morphologie code pour au final assez peu
de
enfin compte pour assez peu de ce qu'on
a dans l'ADN donc la morphologie étant
représentant étant représenté dans l'ADN
par très peu de Gênes au final
essentiellement des gènes du
développement
bah du coup le ce sont des gènes
importants mais n'empêche que la
totalité du génome en lui-même est très
similaire entre le chihuahua et le
doberman et enfin vous avez la
définition morphologique donc avec ça
vous aurez les trois principales
définitions
la définition morphologique de l'espèce
c'est si de Macha se ressemblent
suffisamment
alors on va faire l'hypothèse que c'est
la même espèce
ça paraît con comme ça mais c'est ce
qu'on fait en paléontologie en
paléontologie
on n'a pas le choix on peut pas si vous
voulez vous prenez un crâne
vous prenez un crâne de mots erectus
vous prenez un crâne d'australopithèque
vous pouvez les cogner tant que vous
voulez tout ce que vous obtiendrez c'est
de la poudre de crâne et rien d'autre et
si vous voulez laisser dans une boîte
pendant 20 ans vous ressortirez un crâne
d'australopithèque et un crâne d'Homo
erectus et c'est tout vous ressortirez
pas à descendant parce que c'est pas
reproduire des fossiles c'est pas
possible ça se reproduit pas les
fossiles
donc la définition biologique ne
s'applique pas il y a que de très rares
cas comme l'homme de Néandertal par
exemple ou la définition génétique peut
s'impliquer et dans ce cas là la
définition génétique nous indique que
l'homme de Néandertal est suffisamment
distinct enfin les gènes de l'Homme de
Néandertal sont suffisamment distincts
des gènes d'Homo sapiens pour qu'on
puisse l'appeler une espèce différente
par contre parmi ces gènes on retrouve
des traces de d'hybridation ce qui veut
dire que du point de vue génétique
Néandertal est distinct d'Homo sapiens
par contre vu qu'on a des traces
d'hybridation du point de vue de
l'espèce biologique Néandertal espiasse
sont de la même espèce
donc en plus il y a des conflits vous
voyez entre les entre les définitions
et les créationnistes ils adorent ça les
créationsnistes ils adorent ces conflits
là parce que du coup ça leur permet de
surfer sur le flou artistique de ce que
espèce veut dire
d'autant que les créationnistes en plus
il va en jouer avec une autre définition
de l'espèce qui est la définition
biblique
donc ce qu'ils appellent le kind en
anglais et je sais pas comment ils vont
traduire ça en français mais le kind
donc le type on va dire
où les races je crois que dans dans la
Bible dans la Bible version française il
me semble qu'il traduise ça par race
mais donc le kind c'est une définition
biblique et alors ça englobe tout c'est
ça englobe tout tant que ça m'arrange
vous voyez c'est un peu ça le
on fait un peu de tout tant que ça
m'arrange donc les pour eux les cailles
de ne peuvent pas se croiser donc
généralement ça recouvre la définition
biologique mais comme la plupart des
créationsnistes sont incapables de faire
la différence entre la définition
biologique et la définition
morphologique parce que pour eux si les
gènes sont différents la morphologie
doit être différente alors que j'aime
vous dire que le chihuahua et le
doberman ils ont des gènes qui sont
globalement les mêmes mais la
morphologie est hyper différente et ils
ne peuvent pas se reproduire entre eux
donc comme pour eux de grosses
différences génétiques doivent forcément
résulter en de grosses différences
anatomiques alors que c'est pas vrai du
tout
pour eux il va y avoir un overlap une
recouvrement assez dramatique assez ouf
entre la définition biologique génétique
et enfin bref ils font ce qu'ils veulent
ils font ce qu'ils veulent et donc là on
vient de
taper dans une bingo là quoi la
définition d'espèce et c'est parti
mais il faut bien se rendre compte que
selon ces trois définitions un chihuahua
et un doberman
sont la même espèce génétique sont deux
espèces morphologiques différentes et
sont deux espèces biologiques
différentes donc si vous voulez un
exemple de spéciation bah le chihuahua
de Berman sont déjà un exemple de
spéciation pour au moins deux des
définitions
de l'espèce
si vous voulez un exemple où on a vu des
espèces divergées à tel point qu'elles
peuvent plus reproduire entre elles nous
avons l'exemple d'un fameux lézard dont
j'avais parlé dans une autre vidéo donc
dans cette vidéo classification poulet
rock n' roll nous parlions donc du
concept d'espèces une fois de plus et on
avait parlé de ces lézards du genre
aspidocellis
dans le qui ont été créés en laboratoire
par croisement
avec des chromosomes en plus et ce
nombre de chromosomes en plus les rangs
de fait incompatibles avec la population
maire de lézard et en l'occurrence on
sait que ça a un phénomène qui s'est
aussi produit dans la nature donc le but
de l'expérience en laboratoire c'était
justement de voir d'où venaient ces
lézards qui avaient cette polyploïde
cette ce nombre de chromosomes
surnuméraires ces chromosome en plus
et donc en laboratoire on a finalement
créé des individus une population
entière d'individus qui n'est plus
capable de se croiser avec sa population
originale on vient de créer une nouvelle
espèce biologique et on sait par
ailleurs qu'il y a d'autres lézards qui
sont capables de s'adapter à un régime
herbivore de façon complètement
naturelle les fameux peu d'artistes de
l'île de Pod mercaru en Croatie donc on
sait que d'un côté on peut avoir une
évolution morphologique importante on
sait d'un autre côté qu'on peut avoir
une évolution génétique importante qui
va conduire à la non la non
compatibilité de deux populations tout
indique que si on laisse suffisamment de
temps et de génération et là je parle de
choses qui sont arrivées en très très
peu de génération en réalité
on va obtenir de la macroévolution on va
obtenir de la spéciation
mais comme les créationsnistes ni le
phénomène de spéciation évidemment qu'il
ne verront eux dans leurs yeux à eux ne
percevront jamais cette macroévolution
parce que dans leurs yeux à eux
la spéciation n'existe pas et s'ils ne
peuvent pas percevoir cette spéciation
ils ne peuvent pas percevoir la
macroévolution c'est par définition ils
sont ils sont pas câblés pour pouvoir de
la macroévolution et donc il vous font
des grands des grands discours comme ce
monsieur qui va vous dire la
microévolution Oui-Oui la macroévolution
non non l'état de sable oui oui les
dunes non non
partir de quel moment appelles-tu et
c'est pour ça que je dis à partir de
quel moment considérez-vous que
l'accumulation de de la définition
biologique de l'espèce la définition
morphologique de l'espèce et ici la
définition génétique puisque ces
moustiques de Londres sont génétiquement
une nouvelle espèce même si
morphologiquement ils sont ils sont
toujours similaires aux moustiques de la
surface de Londres les moustiques du
métro eux
façon génétiquement différents et il ne
se reproduisent pas avec les moustiques
de la surface non pas parce qu'ils ne le
peuvent pas au moins du point de vue
théorique mais parce que ils n'ont pas
le même cycle de reproduction donc comme
ils ont un cycle de reproduction
différent rien n'indique qu'en fait
rien n'a dit qu'en fait la divergence de
ces populations en fait va risque de
vous voyez c'est comme deux bras de
rivière rien indique que le bras ce bras
de rivière que sont les moustiques du du
métro vont retourner fucks
vous retournez ce fondre dans la
population de base des moustiques de la
surface rien n'a dit que ça
l'accumulation des grains de sable
finira par former une dune
mais non pas pour eux pour eux pour eux
à chaque fois c'est une rivière vous
voyez c'est une rivière qui se croise
comme ça c'est une rivière en tresse
c'est pas c'est pas des rivières qui se
séparent comme ça ça n'arrive jamais
pour les rivières qui se séparent
[Applaudissements]
et l'autre le passant un changement
mineur dans la structure d'un bec face à
l'origine de l'oiseau lui-même ces
phénomènes ne se placent pas sur la même
échelle ce sont des problèmes distincts
donc vous voyez la définition la
définition de l'espèce à géométrie
variable et là on y est on est en plein
dedans donc là il dit c'est un
changement morphologique mineur le
développement du bec
c'est un changement génétique mineur
c'est pas des espèces différentes c'est
pas vrai le fait qu'elle ne se
reproduise pas entre elles le fait que
le fait que génétiquement elle soit bien
distincte les unes des autres ça ça
compte pas ce qui compte c'est la
morphologie c'est la mort c'est un
changement mineur donc nous on va pas
appeler ça des espèces différentes non
non il y a pas macroévolution bah oui
mais encore une fois là on retombe sur
le on retombe sur le concept de les
créationnistes ils vont tout faire pour
invalider l'évolution mais rien faire
pour t'expliquer comment c'est possible
c'est à dire que lui il te dit non non
c'est pas de la spéciation et là tu as
envie de lui dire oui mais c'est quoi
l'alternative c'est quoi l'explication
alternative vas-y je t'écoute
c'est quoi les pinsons ils ont été
placés là par la grosse main de Dieu qui
a posé les pinsons ici et mais pour une
raison qu'on ignore il a dit vous allez
vous ressembler beaucoup mais pas trop
plutôt que de faire l'hypothèse de
raisonnable qui les avait un ancêtre en
commun qui a légèrement divergé pour
s'adapter à des régimes alimentaires
différents non non il a placé des trucs
qui se ressemblent un peu mais pas trop
comme ça ici pour une raison qu'on
ignore
et pour une raison qu'on ignore il
ressemble au pinson du continent mais
pas du tout beaucoup et
là il y a pas la théorie de l'évolution
c'est la meilleure explication qu'on a
pour les pinsons de Darwin il y a pas
d'autres explications raisonnables que
ils avaient un ancêtre en commun et
chacun ensuite a fait sa sauce dans son
coin
c'est ça paraît évident en fait c'est
évident que ils ont pas été placés là
par une grosse main parce que c'est une
grosse main avait placé des oiseaux là
il y aurait pas de raison que ces
pinsons se ressemblent du tout il y a
aucune raison théorique
pour qu'une grosse intelligence divine
place des pinsons qui se ressemblent un
peu mais pas trop
ils auraient dû être complètement
différents ceux qui avaient besoin d'un
gros bec aurait dû être des perroquets
ce qui avait besoin d'un petit bec
aurait dû être je sais pas moi des
Corbas
qui butine des fleurs aurait dû être des
colibris mais non ce sont tous des
pinsons il y a pas de pinsons de Darwin
qui butine des fleurs mais vous avez
l'idée
la raison de cette différence importante
le gros doigt magique le gros doigt
magique parce que c'est ça leur
explication l'explication des
créationnistes
c'est l'explication des évolutionnistes
c'est la sélection naturelle et les
autres mécanismes évolutifs se suffisent
à eux-mêmes l'explication des créations
magiques
de preuve impressionne-moi
quelles sont ses preuves on nous parle
de preuves je vous demande où sont ses
preuves on va voir où elles sont
de petites variations successives petite
variation successive ça sent Stéphane
jegould là ça sent la citation
ça sent ça sent la citation hors
contexte de Stephen jegoules vous la
santé
plus le darwinisme pose problème et plus
la conception intelligente apparaît
depuis 1988 le docteur Michael b.i
étudie des systèmes biologiques
complexes qui semblent défier les
explications basées sur la sélection
naturelle
complexe on vous tartine du mot
complexité tout le temps c'est trop
compliqué ta gueule
ah qu'est-ce qu'on va nous donner
à l'école
explications à la biologie et là encore
je n'avais aucune raison d'en douter
[Musique]
il y a des ans environ j'ai lu un
ouvrage intitulé révolution une théorie
en crise écrit par un généticien
australien Michael Dalton
[Musique]
et l'avançait contre la théorie de
Darwin de nombreux arguments
scientifiques que je n'avais jamais
entendu jusque-là et ces arguments
semblaient plutôt convaincants
à ce moment-là j'ai senti monter en moi
une frustration parce que j'avais
l'impression d'avoir été conduit sur une
fausse piste je vais même pas vérifier
qui est Michael Denton et si ce bouquin
existait réellement parce que je n'ai
pas besoin pour l'instant de verre ce
qu'il dit
ce sont des banalités il est en train de
dire là ce que vous ce que vous entendez
là ça me choque pas ce sont pas ce sont
des banalités dans les années 80 la
théorie de Darwin
avait déjà plus de 100 ans
donc oui la théorie de Darwin devait
être de devait être datait elle devait
être remise à jour
ça me choque pas du tout donc je vois
pas si vous voulez là l'erreur ce serait
de tomber dans le panneau et de foncer
voir qui ce Michael Denton et puis
est-ce que c'est un vrai généticien et
puis parce que c'est non ça me choque
pas ça me choque pas même quand on
entend dire ah il y a 1000 savants qui
ont dit la sélection naturelle ne suffit
pas à expliquer l'évolution du vivant et
qui ont signé une pétition qui disait la
théorie d'évolution
la sélection naturelle n'explique pas
oui la sélection naturelle ne suffit pas
à expliquer l'évolution du vivant et
c'est la théorie de Darwin la théorie de
Darwin c'est la sélection naturelle
suffit à expliquer l'évolution du vivant
même Darwin de son vivant a écrit
ensuite un bouquin pour pour expliquer
que en fait non il y a pas que la
sélection naturelle il y a aussi la
sélection sexuelle
c'est à dire que même Darwin de son
vivant avec la a fini par comprendre que
la sélection naturelle tout seul
ça suffit pas
bah voilà donc moi ça me choque pas là
ce qu'il dit ça me choque absolument pas
bah oui c'est juste que c'est monté en
épingle dans une dans une montée
dramatique avec de la musique avec un
scientifique qui dit oh mon dieu je me
suis mis à douter
et bien douter de quoi que ce qu'on
t'avait que la base de la base quand tu
as appris à l'école c'est c'est aussi ça
le truc c'est on vous dit oh mon Dieu on
m'a appris à l'université et que la
théorie de l'évolution elle expliquait
tout et en fait non oui enfin ce qu'on
apprend à l'école c'est ce qu'on apprend
à l'école quoi même à l'université
c'est juste ce qu'on t'apprend j'espère
quand même que tu lis des livres en plus
de tes cours
j'espère quand même que tu te contentes
pas de ce que tes profs sont capables de
te raconter en deux heures de cours
j'espère que tu es pas un gros fainéant
à ce point-là oui
parce que c'est ce qu'on fait hein je
veux dire les profs ils ont comme ça on
leur donne un créneau de 10 heures pour
expliquer à un concept hyper compliqué
bon bah va falloir tailler dans le gras
il va falloir enlever de
on va forcément perdre de la matière
quoi il y a forcément un moment il va
falloir que je fasse une slide en disant
c'est vachement plus compliqué que ça
enfin slide une diapositive en français
parce que les grands inquisiteurs du
français donc il y a forcément un moment
où dans mon présentation va y avoir une
diapositive qui dira bon normalement
c'est autrement plus compliqué que ça
mais comme je suis gentil je vous
épargne mais je vous encourage fortement
à lire tel bouquin ah bah oui
faut bien vous imaginer que 10 heures de
cours ça a l'air d'être beaucoup en
réalité c'est très peu pour expliquer
des concepts assez velus donc il faut
lire à côté faut pas se contenter de ce
qu'on vous a appris à l'école si vous
voulez vous prétendre expert parce que
après on n'est pas on peut pas être
expert en tout et je suis d'accord par
contre ouvrir sa gueule sur tout et
n'importe quoi ça nécessite d'être un
expert
ouvrir sa gueule sur la théorie de
l'évolution ça nécessite de comprendre
la théorie de l'évolution or quand je
vois des gens comme dans ce documentaire
qui nous disent mais l'alléatoire ça ne
peut pas expliquer la complexité du
vivant bah c'est que t'as pas compris la
théorie de l'évolution c'est que tu es
un gros jar de faisan de merde qui
comprend rien et tu devrais pas parler
d'un sujet que tu comprends pas
c'est clairement tu as le droit d'avoir
ton opinion je suis d'accord mais
l'exprimé en public c'est autre chose
l'exprimant en public dans un contenu
YouTube enfin dans un contenu
documentaire qui va toucher des
probablement des centaines de milliers
voire des millions de gens
c'est autre chose c'est un autre niveau
c'est pas ton opinion personnelle tu la
rend public et du coup il faut attendre
à ce que des rageux comme moi
c'est nerveux un petit peu en le
regardant
j'avais devant moi une série de très
bons arguments j'avais décroché à
doctorat en biochimie on a toujours pas
entendu les arguments en question
en ce moment
à la montée dramatique mais quels sont
ces arguments
[Musique]
grande partie des découvertes de la
biologie moderne sur le composant
fondamental de la vie la cellule
du vivant de Darwin les scientifiques
pensaient que l'unité fondamentale de la
vie la cellule n'était qu'un simple
globule de protoplasme un morceau de
gélatine ou quelque chose de facile à
expliquer c'est ce que le savent chez
cette idée demeuré plus ou moins changer
jusqu'au début des années 50 mais
pendant la deuxième moitié du 20e siècle
notre connaissance de la cellule a
totalement explosé
[Musique]
le sous-entendu ici c'est que les
créationnistes auraient tenu compte de
ces changements mais pas les
évolutionnistes
c'est un mensonge géanté n'importe quel
cours de biologie que vous allez suivre
n'importe où dans le monde vous
expliqueront que c'est pas ça je veux
dire il y a aucun il y a jamais eu de
mensonge là-dessus le gars le gars vous
fait passer pour une révolution
scientifique le fait qu'on sache que la
cellule c'est pas du protoplasme
c'est pas un sac à protoplasme
[Musique]
j'ose espérer là ça se dirige vers ça
fait plusieurs fois que je fais des
pronostics alors au bout d'un moment
tous mes pronostics ont l'air d'être
faux mais bref là mon pronostic c'est on
va nous expliquer que la cellule c'est
trop compliqué surtout l'ADN la cellule
c'est trop compliqué et Darwin du coup
il pouvait pas savoir que c'était trop
compliqué et du coup la théorie de
l'évolution est fausse et là tu as envie
de les regarder de leur dire mais gros
est-ce que tu t'imagines vraiment que
les biologistes qui sont aussi
évolutionnistes pour la leur grande
majorité on va au moins dans les années
50 il l'était là est-ce que tu
t'imagines vraiment que c'est
biologistes sont restés ignorants de
cela
est-ce que tu t'imagines réellement
qu'ils ont pas repris la théorie de
l'évolution en se disant bon alors
à quel moment est-ce qu'on a merdé et
comment est-ce qu'on peut remettre à
jour la théorie de l'évolution c'est à
cette époque là que la synthèse néo
darwinienne a été proposée dans les
années 50
Ernst Mayer
le grand papa de la nouvelle synthèse de
l'évolution
à l'époque c'était la synthèse de
l'évolution dans les années 50
c'est c'est là qu'il a justement remise
à jour la théorie de l'évolution
notamment après la découverte de l'ADN
par Watson écrite Watson écrit qui ont
jamais été créationniste
donc on va essayer de vous faire passer
maintenant donc la complexité de la
cellule pour une révolution que les
évolutionnistes dont les évolutionnistes
sont incapables d'expliquer l'origine et
ça moi je vais trouver ça absolument
fantastique étant donné que que si on a
des très bonnes explications pour tout
je suis sûr qu'on
je suis sûr qu'on je suis sûr qu'on va
encore entendre des banalités ça
m'énerve déjà
aujourd'hui les technologies de pointe
révèlement microscopiques très élaborés
démons si petits gardez à coudre de
culture liquide peut contenir plus de 4
milliards de bactéries unicellulaires
dans lesquelles s'entassent des circuits
des côtes d'assemblage des machines
miniatures avec une complexité que
Charles Darwin n'aurait jamais imaginé
c'est là où les molécules et les
cellules maintenant on a découvert des
machines des machines et curieusement la
découverte de tout ça n'a pas du tout
mis à mal la théorie de l'évolution elle
s'est mise à jour on explique très bien
l'origine de tout ça
m'explique très bien l'origine de l'ADN
je vous en ai parlé tout à l'heure on
explique très bien
comment les mécanismes ont pu se mettre
en place notamment le noyau l'écologie
et tout ça là on part des phénomènes
d'endosymbiose on expliquerait bien
l'origine de tous ces composantes
intracellulaires on a de très bonnes
explications si vous voulez la
différence entre le créationnisme et la
théorie de l'évolution c'est que la
théorie de l'évolution à chaque fois
qu'on fait une nouvelle découverte elle
est implicitement remise en question et
doit donc soit incorporer ces nouvelles
découvertes et les expliquer soit mourir
chaque nouvelle découverte par exemple
de fossiles remet en question la théorie
de l'évolution il y a aucune raison a
priori pour que les nouveaux fossiles
qu'on découvre tous les jours
rentre dans un grand schéma qui serait
cohérent avec la théorie de l'évolution
il y a aucune raison pour que moi demain
en mettant un coup de pioche dans Le
Caron dans mes dans mes affleurements il
y a aucune raison que je ne découvre pas
un crâne humain vieux de 200 millions
d'années n'empêche que je suis sûr que
je pourrais passer ma vie entière à
donner des coups de pioche dans le
Carouge je suis certain que j'en
découvrirai jamais
parce que la théorie de l'évolution ça
marche
et que si on devait découvrir un crâne
humain dans le carreau ou là on m'a déjà
sorti l'excuse de du voyageur temporel
alors admettons un crâne de cheval voilà
dans le carreau non le cheval c'est
domestique il aurait pu voyager avec
un crâne de d'un animal qu'on peut pas
transporter dans une machine à voyager
dans le temps
est-ce que c'est possible ça un ours
polaire donc voilà si j'en trouve un
crâne d'ours polaire dans le carreau et
ben vous foutez en l'air toute la
théorie de l'évolution mais je suis
certain qu'on en trouvera jamais mais
n'empêche qu'à chaque fois qu'on
découvre un nouveau fossile dans le
carrous ça pourrait être un crâne d'ours
polaire
et sa maîtresse et à chaque fois qu'on
regarde dans une cellule on pourrait
découvrir une structure qui
effectivement
remettrait complètement en question
l'existence de la théorie de l'évolution
sauf que qu'est-ce qu'on voit quand on
regarde dans une cellule parce que c'est
ça qui est important et c'est ça qu'on
expliquait dans notre vidéo sur le
dessin intelligent qu'est-ce qu'on voit
quand on regarde dans une cellule on
voit de la complexité alors oui avec
tous les guillemets qu'il faut mettre au
mot complexité mais on voit de la
complexité certes mais c'est une
complexité bordélique
c'est bordélique ce qui se passe dans
une cellule c'est pas une complexité
élégante comme le rotor d'un comme le
retard d'un hélicoptère ce qu'on voit
dans la cellule c'est une complexité
bordélique et une grande partie de cette
complexité est inutile
j'attire votre attention sur ce qu'on
appelait autrefois l'ADN poubelle on
l'appelle plus comme ça maintenant mais
cet ADN il a il est tellement
utile que les je sais plus c'est les
oiseaux et les poulpes je crois non non
pas ou très peu
voilà
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a cet ADN non
codant on l'appelle ADN non Caudan
maintenant alors il a des fonctions de
protection certes mais pourquoi d'autres
animaux arrivent très bien à s'en passer
bah parce que il est non Caudan et parce
qu'il sert pas à grand-chose quand même
pourquoi avoir dans notre génome une
vaste majorité de cette complexité qui
sert à quasiment rien
pourquoi est-ce qu'on passe par pourquoi
est-ce que l'ADN quand il est traduit
passe par une phase de transcription et
ensuite de traduction pourquoi on passe
pas directement à la traduction
c'est de la complexité inutile ou très
peu utile on a essayé de me trouver des
excuses en me disant mais si mais la
transcription c'est vachement important
parce que oui c'est la transcription est
vachement importante parce qu'on vous a
appris que c'était une étape
indispensable du phénomène mais oublie
qu'on t'a appris que c'était une étape
indispensable du phénomène et essaie
seulement de trouver en quoi elle est
indispensable
est-ce que est-ce que on pourrait pas
juste simplement s'en passer est-ce
qu'une création divine avec un cahier
des charges
visant à produire quelque chose
d'efficace qui va survivre sur terre
est-ce que cette création divine
n'aurait ne se serait pas passé de toute
cette inutilité pourquoi le côté droit
de votre cerveau commande le côté gauche
de votre corps pourquoi c'est pourquoi
ce croisement des effluves pourquoi
cette complexité
il y a pas de raison il y a pas de
raison si vous croyez que les choses ont
été créées de cette façon par un grand
ingénieur un grand horloger Dieu un
extraterrestre je ne sais quoi pourquoi
cette complexité
pour pourquoi c'est aussi compliqué
pourquoi il y a
pourquoi il y a des nerfs dans votre
corps qui font le tour là jusque
là-haute et qui remonte là c'est le
nervag c'est une branche du nervag qui
part de votre cerveau qui fait le tour
de l'aorte et qui remonte ensuite pour
pour aller innerver votre
une partie de votre gorge votre pharynx
pourquoi ce nerf s'emmerde à faire tout
ça pourquoi cette complexité moi je sais
enfin évolutivement on sait pourquoi ça
a lieu parce que on est descendant des
poissons que chez les poissons le coeur
était situé bien plus près de la tête et
du coup le fait que cette que ce nerf
passe derrière l'aorte ne posait pas
problème puisqu'il allait directement du
cerveau à là où il était censé énerver
en passant derrière la Horde sauf
qu'après la tête et le la tête et les
épaules se sont séparés quand on est
devenu des tétrapodes quand on a appris
à marcher sur Terre on avait besoin
d'une épaule et donc une partie une
partie de l'opercion enfin qui était
autrefois l'opercule des poissons est
devenu notre épaule et du coup tout ça
il y a un coût qui est apparu entre la
tête et le cœur et puis bah du coup le
nerf maintenant il faut qu'il fasse le
tour de l'aorte pour continuer à remplir
son rôle parce que autrement de toute
façon le câblage le câblage ou ça part
direct du mens du cerveau jusqu'à la
gorge n'existe pas et là je vous parle
de chez nous mais imaginez chez la
girafe chez la girafe là vous avez 7
mètres de câble qui servent à rien
pourquoi cette complexité inutile bah ça
les créationsnistes ils sont incapables
de répondre des créationsnistes en fait
ils sont même pas seulement incapables
de répondre pourquoi la complexité
inutile il n'y a même pas pensé c'est à
dire que
95% des contenus créationnistes Dieu la
censé l'épreuve en premier sont vont
vous tartiner de complexité irréductible
c'est ça cet argument ça s'appelle
l'argument de la complexité irréductible
ils vont vous tartiner de complexité
irréductible
et c'est trop compliqué du coup c'est
magique
sans jamais vous dire sans jamais
prendre en compte le fait que cette
complexité est justement trop complexe
et cette complexe et la sélection
naturelle j'en reviens à la sélection
naturelle vous n'avez qu'à chercher ce
qu'on appelle les algorithmes
évolutionnaires
donc algo rythme
et
évoluctionnaire voilà et vous allez voir
je suis sûr que j'ai écrit algorithme
évolutionnaire comme un Chartier
comment ça s'écrit
voilà ça s'écrit comme ça donc vous
allez vous renseigner sur les
algorithmes évolutionnaires ce sont des
les algorithmes évolutionnaires pour
vous l'expliquer rapidement ce sont des
algorithmes ce sont des programmes
des programmes qui fonctionnent par
sélection naturelle donc pour résoudre
un problème qui est a priori insoluble
par des programmes classiques vous savez
des programmes bourrins qui vont
chercher la solution un par un donc vous
donnez un problème d'ingénierie par
exemple à un algorithme évolutionnaire
cet algorithme évolutionnaire va aller
en fait au lieu de chercher
c'est bourrinement
un par un quelle est la meilleure
solution parce que il y a trop de
solutions en fait vous allez utiliser
une approximation et cette approximation
ça va être on va progresser pas à pas et
à chaque pas on va appliquer la
sélection naturelle et à chaque pas
la sélection naturelle va nous permettre
de
de localiser la solution qui est la
meilleure à notre problème et ensuite on
va ré-appliquer la même chose c'est à
dire qu'on va faire un pas de plus dans
toutes les directions regardez quelle
direction est la meilleure prendre la
meilleure pouf on la remet au centre on
regarde pareil on regénère plein de
solutions on regarde laquelle est la
meilleure et ainsi de suite et vous
répétez l'opération comme ça donc à
chaque génération vous appliquez la
sélection naturelle et cette sélection
naturelle va finir par créer une
complexité incroyable que un algorithme
classique n'aurait pas réussi à générer
et donc et des solutions
ultra optimisées
surprenamment optimale à des problèmes
qu'on pensait insolubles
c'est ça les algorithmes évolutionnaires
donc ces algorithmes évolutionnaires en
appliquant le principe de la sélection
naturelle génère de la complexité et qui
plus est une complexité qui n'aurait pas
été possible de générer avec des
algorithmes classiques donc je vous
invite à vous renseigner là-dessus juste
pour vous convaincre que si la
complexité est une solution attendue de
la sélection naturelle parce que ça
c'est un a priori que les que les
créationsnistes ils ont aussi c'est
qu'on n'est pas capable de créer de
c'est que la sélection naturelle n'est
pas capable de générer de la complexité
ben si et les algorithmes
évolutionnaires ou algorithmes
évolutionnistes d'ailleurs je regarde
mais apparemment il préfère appeler ça à
l'algorithme évolutionniste
mais bon là en même temps ici les
appellent ça évolutionnaires c'est juste
que c'est difficile à traduire évolution
Harry
évolutionary on traduit des fois
évolutionnaire évolutionniste c'est pas
juste un problème de traduction c'est
tout c'est pas grave
ces algorithmes donc nous démontre enfin
illustre comment la sélection naturelle
peut générer de la complexité et ça
c'est un a priori des créationsnistes
qui oublient tout le temps en fait c'est
c'est un autre de leurs actions c'est
pour eux la complexité génétique fait
forcément de la complexité morphologique
et un autre de leurs actions c'est
la sélection naturelle ne peut pas
générer de la complexité merci
[Musique]
on en a la preuve
ceci étant dit c'est quasiment la même
chose que ce que Richard dokkins avait
fait déjà dans les années 70 avec avec
son horloge aveugle dans son bouquin
l'horloger aveugle c'était plus ou moins
ce que Richard dokkins avait déjà fait
il avait créé en appliquant une
heuristique similaire à la sélection
naturelle mais qui était qui était
manuel qui n'était pas algorithmique en
l'occurrence donc manuellement en
appliquant la sélection naturelle il
avait fini par obtenir des formes ultra
complexes et ceci est sans rappeler que
la complexité existe déjà par elle-même
encore une fois les polyribonucléotides
ça semble tout seul on a déjà parlé au
début de la vidéo les chaînes de
nucléotides ça semble tout seul sur des
verbes asiatiques
donc la complexité n'a pas besoin de la
de sélection naturelle de toute façon
pour exister
ça il faut le rappeler aussi les formes
complexes dans la nature ça existe
et quand vous connaissez la géologie
vous le savez
regardez les structures cristallines
vous verrez il y a de la complexité sans
sélection naturelle
bref on continue
[Musique]
en énergie utilisable
il y a autant de machines moléculaires
que de fonctions organiques dans le
corps humain le fait d'entendre de voir
de sentir de goûter de toucher la
coagulation sanguine la fonction
respiratoire la réponse immunitaire tous
sont appelés une multitude de machines
et tous sont sujets à sélection
naturelle donc son potentiellement
d'origine évolutive
si vous montrez une machine si vous
arrivez à me montrer une machine
d'une
complexité incroyable une machine
biochimique organique dans un dans un ça
fait partie des preuves là justement que
la théorie de l'évolution serait fausse
c'est si vous arrivez à me montrer
un phénomène biologique
ultra complexe ou biochimique en
l'occurrence
ultra complexe
qui n'aboutit à du rien
c'est à dire que la sélection naturelle
aurait zappé complètement
là à la limite tu vois je serai je serai
un peu plus convaincu tu vois mais là
vous me montrez des phénomènes
biologiques biochimiques qui aboutissent
à un meilleur phénotype donc quelqu'un
de bien quelqu'un de qui va mieux
survivre
respirer c'est important donc la
sélection naturelle elle agit là-dessus
donc c'est normal que la sélection
naturelle
produisent des machineries cellulaires
qui sont capables de vous permettre de
respirer c'est normal c'est pas une
conséquence inattendue de la sélection
naturelle
salut tout ce qui sont ce qui sont en
train de vous dire c'est tout se passe
bien dans le meilleur des mondes bah oui
tout se passe bien mais en même temps tu
es en train de regarder les survivants
évidemment que s'il a survécu c'est
qu'il respire bien c'est que sa
machinerie cellulaire fonctionne donc
c'est que la sélection naturelle n'a pas
buté va plutôt voir la liste des
perdants vous savez là les fœtus sont
bocaux dans les facultés de médecine ça
c'est la liste des perdants ça c'est eux
qui ont perdu à la sélection naturelle
c'est cela qu'il faut que tu ailles voir
ceux-là qui sont intéressants ceux qui
ont survécu bah c'est normal qu'ils
fonctionnent puisqu'ils ont survécu le
gars ils ont passé le filtre de la
sélection naturelle ils ont survécu
donc c'est la tautologie c'est ce qui
sont en train de vous dire c'est une
tautologie en fait c'est du panglossisme
tout se passe bien dans le meilleur des
mondes bah oui en même temps si le monde
fonctionne c'est précisément parce que
ça fonctionne
va voir là où ça va pas fonctionner par
contre c'est là où ça devient
intéressant
et puis d'ailleurs je le dis je le dis
mais effectivement si vous arrivez à me
trouver un mécanisme cellulaire qui
existe encore malgré le fait qui sert à
rien va encore enfin ce serait
effectivement un coup dur pour la
l'évolution encore pourrait-on trouver
des explications parce que l'évolution
n'est pas en manque d'explication pour
des trucs inutiles il y a plein de trucs
qui sont inutiles il suffit que il soit
évolution évolutivement neutre c'est à
dire que si ça produit pas de phénotype
bah la sélection naturelle peut pas agir
dessus si ce phénomène
ultra complexe est attaché
ultra complexe mais inutile et attaché à
un autre gène qui lui est absolument
essentiel à la survie bah ce phénomène
ultra complexe et inutile
va forcément rester simplement parce que
tu peux pas t'en débarrasser sans te la
sélection naturelle ne peut pas s'en
débarrasser sans se débarrasser aussi du
gène qui est du gène hyper utile qui est
associé c'est ce qu'on appelle la
pléiotropie la pléiotropie c'est quand
deux gènes sont attachés donc s'il y a
un gène qui sert à quelque chose mais
que l'autre gêne sert à rien bah sachant
que les deux gènes sont en fait
confondus l'un dans l'autre et que c'est
en fonction de comment le l'ADN est
replié que que l'un ou l'autre va
s'exprimer bah
vous pouvez pas vous débarrasser de l'un
sans vous débarrasser de l'autre donc on
a des explications pour ça il y a aussi
les héritages phylogénétiques par
exemple si les petits bras de T-Rex une
fois de plus
c'est T-Rex étant lui-même descendant
d'un animal qui avait quatre bras qui
avait deux bras de jambes bah il a deux
bras de jambes aussi même si il se sert
pas de ses bras ça sert à rien de
produire des bras pour lui mais bon il
est descendant d'un animal qui avait
deux bras de jambes donc il a tout le
matos génétique pour fabriquer deux bras
de jambes
et ce matos génétique il est régulable
que dans une certaine mesure avant
justement de que la pléiotropie foutent
en l'air aussi les jambes donc c'est
très dur de se débarrasser des bras sans
se débarrasser des jambes c'est pas
impossible mais c'est très très dur et
vous
parce que c'est la même machine riz
génétique les oméogènes donc donc
l'évolution elle aurait des explications
même pour un phénomène absolument
complexe et inutile s'il a eu une
utilité par le passé alors c'est normal
qu'ils sont encore là même s'il est plus
utile à l'inverse
les créationsnistes ils seront bien
emmerdés avec ça par contre les
créationsnistes ils seront bien bien
emmerdés parce que si vous avez un
phénomène
ultra complexe mais complètement inutile
ça rentre où dans le carrier des charges
de la création ça
comment vous expliquer que la grande
création qui est censée être parfaite
par définition
produisent un truc aussi imparfait
donc panglossisme
des années 90 Michael commençait à faire
part de ses doutes sur les capacités de
la sélection naturelle à construire des
machines moléculaires complexes une
machine en particulier attira son
attention
ah le flagelle
[Musique]
donc il y a
il y a effectivement donc les arguments
dont on me dit waouh il y a tellement
d'arguments pour dire que la sélection
naturelle ça marche pas et donc on va
s'arrêter sur le flagelle visiblement
c'est parti ne se sent sûrement pas
assemblée au hasard
[Musique]
et pareil le flagelle bactérien
la complexité réelle d'un flagelle
bactérien
et que vous allez pas juste sur la page
Wikipédia
alors là voilà là là on a des là il se
passe autre chose là c'est quand même
une autre un autre niveau de complexité
donc c'est pareil c'est l'argument de la
complexité il est à double tranchant
pour ses créationsnistes c'est à dire
que c'est pas encore une fois c'est pas
une complexité élégante le flagelle
bactérien c'est une [ __ ] d'usine à gaz
et si ça ressemblait à un retard
d'hélicoptère comme il aimerait vous
faire croire dans ce documentaire ça les
arrangerait mais c'est pas le cas
elle est tout à fait acceptée par les
biologistes par les évolutionnistes donc
elle est pas c'est pas un problème ça
c'est publié dans trending my probiology
qui est un des plus prestigieux journal
scientifiques plus prestigieux journaux
scientifiques au monde c'est des
évolutionnistes qui publient là dedans
ça le lait gêne pas parce que c'est une
complexité ridiculement complexe
et c'est ridiculeusement complexe parce
que ça a été justement c'est des petits
incréments c'est à dire qu'il a fallu
prendre des détours c'est comme il dit
vous pouvez pas prendre il va il va vous
dire dans deux minutes parce que je le
connais cet argument c'est toujours
l'argument de la complexité réductible
vous pouvez pas avoir un bout de fleurs
un bout de ce flagelle bactérien qui
évolue tout seul comme ça sans raison
non c'est si vous avez qu'une seule
partie effectivement de la structure
moléculaire de ce flagel qui apparaît
elle va servir à rien ça je suis
d'accord mais par contre ce que les
sélections naturelles proposent comme
explication ce dont à quoi on s'attend
c'est que ce flagel bactérien il a
évolué par petits incréments
effectivement
la première étape du flagel étant
justement un truc qui remue mais de
façon très simple ça c'est pas dur à
produire avec des molécules d'actines
c'est pas dur de produire un petit
mouvement d'un cil et qui ensuite va
accumuler des mutations jusqu'à devenir
une structure complètement
enfin une structure efficace mais très
complexe mais qui dont la fonction
pourra être remplacée par autre chose
alors en l'occurrence pour le flagel
bactérien je m'y connais pas
suffisamment pour vous expliquer que ce
qui s'est produit et quels sont les
hypothèses en vigueur en ce moment par
contre par exemple je peux vous prendre
l'exemple des fans des baleines
l'exemple des fanons des baleines les
les fans des baleines ce sont pas des
dents qui se sont transformés alors un
créationniste il va vous dire ah bah tu
vois les fans des baleines c'est pas des
dents qui ont évolué donc c'est
forcément elles ont été créées comme ça
et tu peux pas survivre avec une moitié
de Fanon tu vois ils vont dire ça c'est
ça la complexité irréductible tu peux
pas survivre une baleine elle pourrait
pas survivre sans dents avec juste une
moitié de Fanon bah oui mais en fait une
église le fait que la que la que les
dents étaient là chez les premières
baleines et les dents étaient là et le
l'exemple du phoque crabienne nous
montre très bien comment les dents
peuvent être utilisés pour filtrer l'eau
donc tu peux très bien avoir une étape
où les baleines filtrer l'eau juste avec
leurs dents une étape suivante où les
dents et les premiers fanons là les demi
fans dont ils disent qu'ils sont
impossibles c'est impossible d'avoir de
survivre avec des demi-fanons bon bah là
tu as les demi fanons et les dents là
est dans l'autre et l'autre et dans l'un
dans sa fonction et à la fin quand les
fanons ont suffisamment pris en ampleur
pour être autosuffisant les temps
finissent par disparaître parce que ça
sert plus à rien de les utiliser et que
c'est de l'énergie physiologique gâchée
donc on gagne un avantage évolutif à ne
pas développer dedans et donc ça c'est
ce qu'on pourrait appeler la théorie de
l'échafaudage c'est à dire que c'est
bien joli de regarder une cathédrale en
se disant regardez cette cathédrale elle
est tellement magnifique elle a pas pu
elle a pas pu être construite par des
êtres humains ou les pyramides en
l'occurrence par exemple
regarder les pyramides et vous dites
waouh mais regardez c'est pyramide c'est
trop compliqué et pour que ça a été fait
par des êtres humains mais c'est oublier
toutes les constructions qui a eu avant
elle et autour d'elle voilà la
cathédrale c'est plus parlant les
cathédrales de à peu près tout le monde
est au courant que généralement à
l'emplacement des cathédrales avant il y
a eu une église
et que autour de la cathédrale il y a eu
un échafaudage voyez la cathédrale elle
s'est pas elle a pas été matérialisée là
par des extraterrestres donc la
cathédrale il y a bien fallu qu'elle se
construise qu'elle se construisent
quelque part et elle s'est construit en
l'occurrence par dessus quelque chose
d'autre ce quelque chose d'autre a
laissé des cicatrices sur la cathédrale
et il a fallu des échafaudages et c'est
des échafaudages pareil ils laissent des
cicatrices aussi et on sait pareil pour
le flagelle c'est à dire que si les
flagelle avait été formés selon un
cahier des charges tel quel dans sa
forme la plus fonctionnelle bah ce
serait effectivement un retard
d'hélicoptère mais en l'occurrence c'est
pas le cas le flagel c'est une structure
qui est incroyablement plus complexe et
donc le créationnisme ne permet pas
d'expliquer l'origine du flagelle non
plus
c'est incroyablement plus complexe et
c'est une complexité qui peut être
expliquée
par la théorie de l'évolution selon le
l'hypothèse de l'échafaudage à savoir
que le flagel qu'on connaît chez les
bactéries aujourd'hui est probablement
lui-même issu d'une structure
préexistante qui est lui-même dérivé
d'une structure préexistante
et du coup on a les cicatrices de ces
structures préexistantes qui sont encore
là dans le flagelle moderne plus
l'échafaudage qui a eu autour voyez ça
veut pas dire le fait qu'il y ait un
flagelle aujourd'hui chez les bactéries
veut pas dire qu'il y a pas eu à un
moment par exemple des flagelles qui
avaient à la fois des cils et des
flagelles et donc il pouvait se qu'il
pouvait bouger grâce au cils et aux
flagelles en même temps donc oui le
flagel exemple presque préféré j'ai
envie de dire de nos amis les
créationsnistes mais pareil ils y ont
pas suffisamment réfléchi le flagelle
c'est trop complexe même pour les
créationsnistes en réalité et ça ça vous
vous allez mettre ça sur le nez d'un
créationniste dans cet argument là vous
verrez comment il s'en sort c'est très
rigolo
spoiler alert il s'en sort pas
la complexité inéligante ça c'est
un truc
ils ont du mal
i en milieu liquide dépend d'un ensemble
de composants mécaniques très élaborés
les composants de ce système
apparaissent au microscope quand des
échantillons de cellules sont
grossissent 5
en fonction des photos de microscopie
électronique comme celle-ci pour
identifier les composants et la
structure tridimensionnelle du moteur
flagellaire
[Musique]
c'est ainsi qu'ils ont découvert une
pure merveille technique à l'échelle
miniature
de ces moteurs ont une vitesse de
rotation de 100000 tours par minute
si on de signaux ou sensoriel qui leur
fournit des informations sur
[Musique]
le bœuf s'arrêter
on a eu le tour par minute dans une
autre direction
[Musique]
et pourtant dans son extrême magnifique
science Dieu a oublié de filer des yeux
et un sens de la direction à ses
bactéries
c'est à dire que c'est quand même une
quantité d'efforts phénoménale déployée
pour produire la machine la plus
perfectionnée du monde la machine c'est
biochimique la plus perfectionnée du
monde
et c'est connes de bactéries sont pas
capables d'aller tout droit parce
qu'elles ont pas Dieu ni aucun sens de
où elles veulent aller
ah merde
[Rires]
ah merde alors je savais on était à ça
on était à ça
[Rires]
ah non c'est dommage
tu es juste ouais le même flagel
bactérien à échelle humaine avec nos
yeux et notre cerveau pour pour que ça
serve réellement à quelque chose
et là éventuellement je serai un petit
peu je dis bien un tout petit peu
inquiet pour la théorie de Darwin là
effectivement je me dirais ouais non là
il y a un alignement de planètes qui est
ouf là là c'est ouf ce qui vient de se
passer là on a vraiment tu sais genre
les gens les gens qui sont montés sur
propulseur comme ça même sur un poisson
je dis ça sur un être humain ça servira
à rien moi que ça sert d'hélicoptère
mais sur un poisson tu vois un flagelle
et le machin il peut aller à 200 km/h
comme ça dans une direction donnée là je
serais impressionné mais alors là tu as
fait ce montage de fou sur un organisme
ou basiquement tu souffles dessus il
s'envole
ce flagelle bactérien mais quelle folie
c'est genre ça se comporte comme du
plancton tu vois ce que je veux dire
c'est juste du plancton tu fous ça dans
l'eau et bah ça suit les courants même
avec son flagelle ultra perfectionné
c'est genre encore une fois c'est
inutilement complexe
c'est
c'est ouf c'est ouf
et tout comme un moteur hors-bord ils
sont composés d'un grand nombre
d'éléments indispensables au
fonctionnement de l'ensemble le flagel
IEN
la refroidissement liquide et d'une
force des aloïdes et à terme un crochet
un arbre de transmission une hélice ses
composants fonctionnent comme un moteur
on emploie ces termes maladroits pour
décrire en fait la fonction de ses
éléments
couverts
et Dieu a mis cette fantastique machine
sur les bactéries conclusion Dieu
préfère les bactéries
les scientifiques ont essayé de
comprendre comment un moteur rotatif a
pu résulter de la sélection naturelle
jusqu'à présent ils n'ont pas été en
mesure de fournir une explication
darwinienne détaillée
[Musique]
le problème réside dans une
caractéristique des machines
moléculaires appelées complexité et
réductible
[Musique]
exité en résumé tout organole ou système
dans une cellule et fait de plusieurs
composants tous essentiels pour son
fonctionnement si on enlève un de ces
éléments le système ne fonctionne plus
[Musique]
le piège est composé de 5 pièces le
déclencheur où on pose la part un
ressort puissant un film
le piège à souris acné directement sorti
de Bugs Bunny
pourquoi le
[Musique]
mécanique la complexité c'est un exemple
parfait c'est moi moi je trouve ça je
trouve ça absolument parfait pour
illustrer la complexité irréductible et
toutes les faiblesses de la complexité
réductible c'est à dire qu'en fait le la
présentation qui vous a été faite de ce
piège à souris
si elle était interprétée exactement
comme pour le flagel bactérien en fait
voudrait dire qu'avant le piège à souris
il y avait pas de piège à souris
et c'est faux
piéger les souris bien avant le piège à
souris le fameux échafaudage dont je
vous parlais c'est il y a l'échafaudage
dans l'occurrence c'est tous les autres
modèles de pièges à souris qui ont
préexister au piège à souris acné qui
viennent de vous présenter
plein de il y a plein de pièges à souris
et qui ont préexister au piège à souris
qui vous ont montré tout ça c'est
l'échafaudage ces bactéries avaient
certainement d'autres manières de se
propulser avant d'avoir le superflagel
over the top qu'ils ont maintenant et
c'est mécanisme ont été cooptés ont
servi d'échafaudage on s'est servi de
base pour construire un mécanisme plus
compliqué après donc ils sont restés
actifs ces anciens mécanismes en même
temps que le nouveau mécanisme se
développait exactement comme les fanons
des baleines ce sont développés en même
temps que les dents étaient toujours là
en fait
donc la théorie de l'évolution n'a
absolument aucun problème avec la
complexité irréductible la complexité de
réductible c'est un argument qui a été
contré depuis très longtemps par Richard
dokkins d'ailleurs et par plein d'autres
mondes c'est pas un argument de nouveau
d'ailleurs à la complexité
on compte en tout environ 40 composants
de protéines qui font tourner cette
machine
si le crochet ou l'arbre de transmission
est absent par exemple le flagel ne
fonctionnera pas ou ne sera même pas
assemblée dans la cellule
ça veut dire que s'il y a un composant
du flagel qui merde la sélection
naturelle va s'en débarrasser favorisant
ainsi les bactéries qui ont un meilleur
flagelle et donc l'évolution vers des
bactéries plus performantes
merde
ce système
pour pas en place
un échafaudage réponse trouvée en bas
la complexité irréductible des machines
moléculaires posent un défi d'envergure
aux possibilités de la sélection
naturelle
selon la théorie de Darwin
peuvent être assemblés
mais comme le préciser Darwin l’œil peut
tellement être assemblée graduellement
qu'en réalité si vous regardez la nature
actuelle vous avez toutes les étapes
graduelles de la formation d'un œil dans
les espèces vivantes aujourd'hui
vous avez tout depuis la simple cellule
photoréceptrice votre peau votre peau
est fait de cellules qui sont
photoréceptives puisque elles répondent
à la lumière en fabriquant de la
mélanine c'est ce qu'on appelle le
bronzage donc c'est photorécepteur vous
avez les eaux selles des invertébrés
genre les plats telmates les Verts vous
avez et vous avez tout en fait jusqu'au
Nautil le Nautil qui a un œil qui est
quasiment le même que celui des humains
avec je sais plus quel composant en
moins je crois qu'il leur manque la
lentille ou un truc comme ça mais bref
vous avez vous avez littéralement tous
les exemples possibles de photos
réception dans la nature
la sélection naturelle ne peut être
efficace que si ces modifications
génétiques aléatoires offrent un
avantage à l'organisme qui évolue dans
sa lutte pour la survie
[Musique]
comme j'ai essayé de le montrer encore
une fois en partant du principe que la
sélection naturelle est le seul et
unique
phénomène
[Musique]
parce que encore une fois on est
toujours dans un on est toujours dans un
contexte créationniste ou on s'imagine
que la sélection naturelle de Darwin est
le seul et unique mécanisme or les
transferts horizontaux ça existe les les
organismes s'échangent des gènes des
gènes qui sont déjà tout fait et qui
fournissent un avantage tel quel à
d'autres organismes ils le font pas par
bonté d'âmes c'est généralement des
virus qui font ça parce que les virus
évidemment ils piquent des gènes d'un
côté ils piquent des gènes de l'autre
les bactéries font ça aussi des fois
mais les transferts horizontaux ça
existe par exemple vous pourrez
m'expliquer en long en large et en
travers comment le la syncytine et c'est
impossible que la syncytine soit apparue
comme ça parce que la syncytine c'est
trop compliqué la syncytine c'est ce qui
permet la fusion du du placenta avec le
les vaisseaux sanguins de la mer donc
c'est ce qui permet les échanges entre
la mer et le bébé à travers le placenta
c'est dû à une molécule qui s'appelle la
syncy vous pourrez m'expliquer en large
et en travers comment la syncytine n'a
pas pu apparaître comme ça par magie
chez les chez les mammifères parce que
c'est trop compliqué une année ni nanana
bah oui mais en l'occurrence la ça
sitine est effectivement apparue comme
ça par magie chez les mammifères parce
qu'elle a été transférée par un virus
c'est une c'est une en fait une molécule
virale c'est en fait une enfin c'est une
molécule qui est d'origine virale donc
c'est les virus qui nous sont transmis
les gènes pour fabriquer la syncytine
donc c'est un transfert horizontal
pourrait m'expliquer en long en large et
en travers comment les la cellule c'est
trop compliqué il y a des mitochondries
dedans et les mitochondries c'est pas
possible ils ont pas pu apparaître comme
ça c'est toute formé c'est trop
compliqué si on enlève n'importe quel
petit bout d'une mitochondrie la
mentochondrie elle fonctionne pas et
être à la la oui mais les mitochondries
ce sont des micros organismes entiers
qui ont été complètement absorbés par
des cellules eucaryotes les
mitochondries elles ont été bouffées
littéralement par les eucaryotes ce sont
des procaryotes donc des bactéries qui
ont été bouffées par des eucaryotes
c'est-à-dire des cellules à noyaux
et ça a donné les mitochondries la
cellule à noyau ayant tiré un bénéfice
de l'absorption de cette mitochondrie
qui produisait de l'énergie tu vois la
mitochondrie est en tiré un avantage de
là en produisant de l'énergie au moins
elle se faisait pas digérer tu vois ben
c'est comme ça que ça s'est produit les
transferts horizontaux mesdames et
messieurs ça permet de générer de la
complexité instantanée comme ça je vais
pas claquer le doigt trop fort parce que
ça va faire saturer le micro mais ça
permet de générer une énorme complexité
d'un seul coup et sans passer par la par
le phénomène long et fastidieux d'une
évolution d'un gradualisme phileétique
lent
c'est une sorte d'équilibre ponctuaire
en fait c'est exactement ce que Stephen
jegould d'essayer de d'expliquer aux
créationsnistes quand il a inventé les
les équilibres ponctués c'est que non
simplement à valider le gradualisme
phytique de Darwin nous disait Stephen
jegould enfin disait Stephen gigould au
créationniste ça ne suffit pas à valider
l'évolution tout entière vous ne faites
qu'un valider un des mécanismes un des
multiples mécanismes il existe les
transferts horizontaux par exemple il
existe le la dérive génétique la dérive
génétique qui fait naître une complexité
assez ouf assez rapidement simplement
parce que il y a pas assez de diversité
en fait donc en gros vous avez une c'est
la consanguinité quoi c'est une
consanguinité qui fonctionne
c'est chiant à accomplir mais ça arrive
généralement sur les îles par exemple et
donc vous allez générer quelque chose de
très aberrant très très vite
et encore une fois
comment vous expliquer ça quand vous
êtes créationniste
donc là on vous créez un homme de paille
qui est l'évolution c'est que la
sélection naturelle c'est faux
on est capable de d'expliquer la
complexité
scientifique en doute simple comment une
chose nouvelle comme ce motorfly et tous
ses composants auraient-ils pu décoller
d'une population de bactéries qu'il
possède pas
ceci une phrase qui se résume parce
qu'on prend pas comment faire arriver
alors ça a pas pu arriver
je comprends pas comment ma télé
fonctionne alors ma télé elle fonctionne
pas ma télé n'existe pas voilà
dans la théorie de Darwin doit entraîner
des avantages
non pas forcément encore une fois
remettez-vous à jour les mutations non
il y a ce qu'on appelle des malades
adaptations en biologie évolutive et
c'est mal adaptations peuvent avoir des
des origines divers et variées mais
elles sont très très bien intégrées à la
théorie de l'évolution
c'est ce que je parlais tout à l'heure
par exemple à pléiotropie la pléiotropie
si vous avez une merde accrochée à un
gène qui est absolument indispensable et
que les deux sont indissociablement liés
dans votre génome vous allez vous de
voir vous trimballer cette merde quand
même
tant pis on en parlait d'ailleurs dans
notre épisode dédié à la mort si je me
rappelle bien c'est pourquoi la mort est
la preuve de l'évolution darwinienne et
notamment comment certains gènes qui
vous rendent plus féconds messieurs
voilà dans des gènes qui augmentent qui
booste votre sécrétion de testostérone
et donc vont vous rendre plus fécond et
aussi plus musclé plus attractif et bien
messieurs ces jeunes vous rendent aussi
beaucoup plus susceptibles au cancer des
testicules
oui monsieur et puis l'équivalent existe
aussi pour les dames les mêmes gènes qui
vous font grossir les seins et qui vous
rendent plus féconde qui vous font
sécréter plus de ce projet par exemple
et bien c'est même gêne vont aussi vous
rendre plus susceptible au cancer du
sein et des ovaires donc par exemple la
mort et la reproduction c'est ce qui est
dit ici sont indissociablesment
génétiquement liés et ce documentaire
bah il fait complètement la passe
là-dessus sur le fait que non tous les
changements dans un contexte darwinien
devons pas vous fournir des avantages
c'est pas vrai ce n'est pas ce que les
évolutionnistes disent ce n'est pas ce
que les évolutionnistes pensent c'est
votre opinion mal informé messieurs les
créationnistes
c'est votre opinion mal informé de ce
qu'est la théorie de l'évolution et
c'est pour ça que quand on y connaît
rien il faudrait mieux fermer sa tronche
au début de l'histoire terrestre
même les pièces nécessaires pour
l'acrope mais sans l'assemblage complet
du moteur cette innovation n'apporterait
aucun avantage à la cellule
la queue resterait immobile
de favoris
sauf si cette queue servait à autre
chose à la base scénario de la
préadaptation
développée aussi par Stephen gegould en
tout cas rendue populaire par Stephen
gegould peut-être que cette queue
bactérie peut-être que cette queue
servait à pêcher d'autres organismes
dont la bactérie se nourrissait dans les
bactéries normalement elles font pas ça
mais
la préadaptation c'est pareil par
exemple pour le cas des plumes vous
pourriez dire ah les plumes des oiseaux
modernes sont beaucoup trop évoluées
elles ont pas pu apparaître tu peux pas
voler avec la moitié d'une plume c'est
pas possible complexité et réductible
c'est négliger le fait que les plumes à
la base servaient surtout d'isolant
thermique puis elles ont servi à
augmenter l'aérodynamisme sans pour
autant permettre de voler puis elles ont
permis de d'augmenter la maniabilité
durant la course rapide etc donc bref il
y a eu des préadaptations avant
l'adaptation finale qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
qui n'est pas final d'ailleurs puisque
dans un contexte darwinien c'est ça
continuera encore d'évoluer le concept
de préadaptation il a un petit arrière
good finalise mais bon c'est juste pour
comprendre le fait que l'adaptation d'un
organisme qu'on enfin l'adaptation d'une
structure qu'on voit aujourd'hui n'est
pas forcément celle pour laquelle il a
évolué à la base et un autre exemple que
j'aime beaucoup c'est le cerveau alors
qui est pas encore un exemple démontré
mais c'est un autre truc c'est j'avais
parlé dans une vidéo récemment sur
l'évolution du cerveau que
éventuellement il est possible que le
gros cerveau des dauphins qui les rend
si intelligent aujourd'hui
est en fait évolué non pas pour de
l'intelligence pour produire de
l'intelligence mais est en fait évolué
surtout pour produire de la chaleur à la
base et donc il a grossi le cerveau
étant un organe très gourmand en énergie
il produit beaucoup de chaleur il a
grossi ça a permis de garder le corps
chaud de produire beaucoup de chaleur
pour garder le corps chaud mais c'est
pas pour l'intelligence qu'il a évolué à
la base donc en fait l'intelligence des
dauphins c'est juste une c'est juste une
conséquence secondaire en fait un effet
à second effet kiss cool de l'évolution
vers un cerveau qui produit surtout
beaucoup de chaleur donc il faut faire
fonctionner les neurones pour que ça
produise de la chaleur et du coup ça
produit de l'intelligence mais au final
c'est pas pour ça qu'il a évolué comme
ça le cerveau
donc encore une fois on n'est pas
complètement même en partant du scénario
stupide qu'il nous donne là parce
qu'évidemment il nous peignent là un
scénario absolument ridicule et
caricaturale de ce que les
évolutionnistes proposeraient comme
explication à l'origine du flagel chez
les bactéries bah même là on n'est pas
démunis
même là on n'est pas du tout démunis on
a des explications il est possible que
ce flagel est existé effectivement à la
base mais pour une autre fonction que la
nage ce qu'on appelle une préadaptation
ce qui est parfaitement intégré dans la
théorie de Darwin et je viens de vous en
donner enfin dans la théorie de
l'évolution qui n'est pas celle que
Darwin a proposé il y a 150 piges mais
bel et bien une version mise à jour la
nouvelle synthèse et cette nouvelle
synthèse elle est pas du tout dépourvue
face à des arguments comme ça on sait on
a des hypothèses du moins on sait pas
qu'on sait mais on a des hypothèses
on n'a pas on n'est pas dépourvu
d'explication comme ils essaient de vous
faire croire
à moins que le mécanisme du flagel soit
complètement
pas le préserver il ne peut être
transmis à la génération
oui ça c'est le truc je suis d'accord je
suis d'accord la sélection naturelle ne
suffit pas à expliquer ça par contre
tous les mécanismes que je viens de vous
dire là après adaptation playotropie et
échafaudage etc tout ça c'est des
mécanismes qu'on connaît dont on sait
qu'ils existent et qui peuvent très bien
expliquer la même chose
donc là fondamentalement tu me montres
cet extrait là comme ça là je dirais oui
je suis d'accord
sélection naturelle mais pas d'expliquer
ça
aussi dans l'exemple des bactéries
lumineux qui ne servent pas le flagelle
il est probable que celle-ci soit
éliminée
la seule raison de sélectionner un
flagel c'est parce qu'il fonctionne et
cela signifie pour commencer que tous
les éléments du moteur flagellaire
soient en place donc la sélection
naturelle ne peut donner lieu à un
flagel bactérien elle ne peut entrer en
jeu qu'après que le flagel soit là et
opération
[Musique]
nelle en 1987 Michael Billy publié un
livre intitulé Darwin Black Box dans
lequel il cherche à montrer que la
sélection naturelle substitue
une diligence Honda win ne pouvait
expliquer l'origine du flagel bactérien
ou de tout autre système biologique
irréductiblement complexe Michael Betty
à la conclusion que la complexité
inhérente à ces systèmes nous aurions
des régions intelligente
et voilà la grande la grande falacie le
grand la grande révélation c'est si
c'est pas la donc ils vous ont dirigé
donc comme je l'avais prédit au début de
la vidéo
la sélection naturelle et le seul
mécanisme qui existe
donc selon les créationsnistes il y a
que la sélection naturelle et
l'aléatoire et donc comme il y a que la
sélection naturelle est que la sélection
naturelle ne suffit pas à expliquer
l'origine du flagel bactérien alors ta
gueule c'est magique le dessin
intelligent parce que je rappelle le
dessin intelligent c'est le gros doigt
magique de Dieu qui vient aider
l'évolution
donc voilà si c'est pas la sélection
naturelle c'est magique et pourquoi il
croit ça parce qu'ils ne connaissent pas
la vraie théorie de l'évolution parce
qu'ils ne savent pas tous les autres
mécanismes dont je viens de vous parler
il ne les connaissent pas ou choisissent
de les ignorer parce que dans les années
80 tous ces arguments ils existaient
c'est Stephen Gould
qui les a mis en place ces arguments
c'est Richard Richard dokkins aussi et
tout ça ils ont fait ça dans les années
70 et 80 il refuse ses créationsnistes
de se mettre à jour
en partant du principe que ce
documentaire de fin d'année 80 début 90
ce qui a l'air d'être le cas vu que
c'est un VHS RIP
il refuse de se mettre à jour ces gens
et c'est agaçant c'est pour ça que j'en
avais marre aussi de faire des des
bagages et pénitence c'est qu'on y
radote ses créationsnistes c'est
horrible et moi du moi aussi du fait je
radote vu que on entend tout le temps
les mêmes arguments bah je répète tout
le temps les mêmes contre arguments
certains scientifiques ça lui ressemble
à la popularité
[Musique]
oh bon le dessin intelligent il y a des
motivations religieuses derrière au bon
Dieu
cette théorie donc je vais pas revenir
là-dessus
[Musique]
du transfert horizontal
en fait on ne peut pas poursuivre cette
pompe bien loin le retour du je
comprends pas comment ça s'est fait
alors ça c'est pas fait
[Musique]
tout autre problème
tu vas voir s'il a pas parlé de ça en
long en large et en travers
n'attend pas seulement de composants
précis mais aussi d'une séquence
d'assemblage minutieuses
soient faites au bon moment on a besoin
du nombre exact d'éléments on doit les
assembler de façon séquentielle il faut
pouvoir déterminer si l'assemblage s'est
bien déroulé pour ne pas gaspiller de
l'énergie pour une structure qui ne sera
pas
la construction d'une machine
moléculaire est comparable à celle d'une
maison ou les ouvriers suivent un plan
d'architecture détaillé
on pose les fondations avant des régir
les murs
on installe la plomberie et le réseau
électrique avant de recouvrir les
cloisons
on doit encastrer les fenêtres avant de
passer la finition extérieure et on pose
les bardots seulement après avoir cloué
le contreplaqué aux chevrons
[Musique]
il nous explique que c'est trop
compliqué d'assembler un flagelle
bactérien
et s'ils ont raison
alors le flagelle bactérien n'existe pas
je prends le micro et je le drop
[Rires]
ce que vous voulez que je vous dise leur
argument il tire une balle dans le pied
tout seul si c'est trop compliqué
d'assembler un flagelle bactérien alors
le flagelle bactérien ne devrait pas
exister
que que
ah pardon j'ai oublié de préciser oui
donc eux ils ont une approche donc
phylogénétique de l'assemblage de la du
flagelle bactérien et là ce que je viens
de faire c'est une approche
ontogénétique du flagel bactérien donc
dit clairement en fait c'est que eux ils
Conflent c'est qu'en fait ils confondent
évolution darwinienne enfin évolution au
sens darwinien et
évolution au sens pokemon
du terme c'est l'évolution au sens
Pokemon c'est en fait c'est la
croissance c'est l'antogénie c'est c'est
vous qui passez de l'âge enfant à l'âge
adulte ça c'est l'évolution mais sauf
que là ce qui viennent de vous expliquer
là c'est que
la phylogénèse du flagel bactérien est
impossible car ce serait trop compliqué
que les séquences soient apparues dans
le bon ordre et Machin tout ça mais
n'empêche que s'ils ont raison
alors l'ontogenèse non plus n'est pas
possible un flagel bactérien si c'est
trop compliqué à assembler en
70 milliards d'années non je dis des
conneries c'est un flagelle bactérien
c'est trop compliqué à assembler en 4
milliards d'années d'évolution comme le
disent les évolutionnistes la vie étant
apparue il y a 4 milliards d'années Noël
les bactéries elles vivent aujourd'hui
donc si le flagel bactérien est trop
compliqué à assembler en 4 milliards
d'années d'évolution alors en vertu de
quoi par Jupiter une bactérie arrive à
le faire aujourd'hui maintenant si elle
naît dans mon bocal dans deux heures
elle est prête non mais moi je demande
je demande en vertu de quoi c'est trop
compliqué pour 4 milliards d'années
d'évolution d'accomplir quelque chose
alors que la même bactérie aujourd'hui
là elle se elle Budd en 15 minutes
de bactéries avec deux flags ultra
complexes en 15 minutes ah bah merde ah
bah merde
c'est trop compliqué pour être
reproductible il faut forcément qu'il y
ait une intelligence supérieure et
bactérie qui n'a même pas de système
nerveux elle arrive à faire ça en 15
minutes dans son dans sa dans son tube à
essai
[Rires]
comme ils disent oh mon dieu c'est pas
possible que un être humain soit apparu
après 7 millions d'années d'évoluent
c'est trop compliqué un être humain il y
a forcément une intelligence
ta maman a produit un être humain en
neuf mois sans y penser sans même avoir
à y penser
voilà
c'est pas possible que l'être humain en
4 milliards d'années est évolué à partir
d'une petite cellule qui s'est
transformée en suite en vertébrés qui
s'est transformé en suite en mammifère
puis en être humain en 4 milliards
d'années vous rendez pas un compte bah
non ta maman l'a fait en 9 mois te faire
passer du stade une cellule au stade
être humain ta maman l'a fait en neuf
mois sans même y penser
sans avoir à y réfléchir
c'est la maman elle a pas passé neuf
mois à faire et maintenant le cerveau
faut pas que je me plante les neurones
faut que je les fasse bien non ta maman
elle a continué à vivre sa vie plus ou
moins confortablement ceci étant dit
mais elle l'a fait elle a fait très bien
là c'est fait ça c'est fait et personne
n'y a réfléchi personne
en vertu de quoi 4 milliards d'années ne
serait pas suffisant pour accomplir
ce qui se fait aujourd'hui en très peu
de temps
et pour en revenir à l'assemblage de la
maison
croyez-vous que les maisons modernes
donc comme ils viennent de les décrire
jusqu'à présent croyez-vous que ces
maisons modernes est toujours existé
ou bien est-ce que les maisons qu'on a
aujourd'hui avec tous leurs matériaux
composites leur assemblage très complexe
ne serait-elle pas le fruit d'une
évolution technologique qui aurait mis
très très longtemps à s'accomplir est-ce
que les maisons d'aujourd'hui ne
seraient pas elles-mêmes le fruit d'une
évolution ou bien est-ce que les êtres
humains ils ont toujours vécu dans des
maisons qui ressemblent aux maisons
d'aujourd'hui je vous le demande est-ce
que ça ce serait pas éventuellement un
argument complètement pété
donc c'est ce que c'est exactement comme
je viens de vous dire ils ont
allègrement mélangé ontogénie et
phylogénie dans le seul but de vous de
vous embrouiller
il en est de même de la construction du
moteur flagellaire
vers l'extérieur
pendant longtemps
vous ressemblez un message indique qu'on
peut passer à la suite une tige est
ajoutée puis un anneau
puis une autre tige
des crochets qui ayant atteint une
certaine taille et inclinaison environ
90 degrés
laisse place à l'assemblage du filament
flagellaire tout ceci intervient selon
un ordre précis à la star de la
construction d'un bâtiment
pour construire le moteur correctement
il faut un système complexe où les
machines respectent minutieusement
l'ordre des instructions d'assemblage
comment la sélection naturelle
pourrait-elle produire un tel système
corruption
en commençant par pas confondre
autogénie et philogénie
exactement votre maison avec ses
matériaux composites et là toute la
technologie qu'elle contient
est construite d'une certaine façon
aujourd'hui mais les maisons dans le
passé n'étaient pas du tout construites
de cette façon là avant et pourtant on
les appelait aussi des maisons et avant
ça on avait des on avait des huttes et
avant ça on avait des abris sous roche
et pourtant
tout cela remplissait la même fonction
ça va rappeler l'échafaudage vous
rappelez la cathédrale de typiquement
l'exemple de la cathédrale que j'ai
utilisé tout à l'heure donc l'exemple de
la cathédrale c'est comment l'on comment
on arrive à construire justement quelque
chose et ça va garder les cicatrices de
toutes les constructions précédentes bon
bah là ils sont là c'était de la
philogénie et donc eux ils sont en train
de confondre autogénie et phylogénie
c'est tout ça c'est et tout ça c'est
ce passage là il est vraiment vraiment
là depuis tout à l'heure c'est vraiment
juste regarder c'est comme ça que la
bactérie génère en 15 minutes là génère
en 15 minutes son flagelle
et on vous dit regardez comment c'est
trop complexe l'évolution un peu plus
produire ça ben oui mais là c'est pas la
même chose en fait c'est pas la même
mécanisme du tout alors je sais qu'il y
a des fois on dit lontogénie récapitule
la phylogénie
mais
mais c'est seulement des fois pour
quelques caractères donc comme par
exemple les
osselets de l'oreille de l'oreille
interne de leurrée moyenne chez les
mammifères ou là effectivement
l'autogénie
récapitule la phylogénie dans le sens où
ce sont bien des éléments embryonnaires
de la mâchoire qui migrent dans
l'oreille exactement ce qu'on voit dans
le registre fossile donc là en
l'occurrence on a une autogénie qui
récapitule la phylogénie
comme on n'a pas de fossiles de
bactéries il y a aucun moyen qu'on
puisse certifier et je pense qu'aucun
évolutionniste ne le certifiera que ce
qu'on vient de nous raconter là sur
l'ontogénie du flagel bactérien
récapitule une quelconque phylogénie
enfin phylogenèse
donc là c'est argument fallacieux jamais
aucun en fait jamais aucun
évolutionnisme vous dira que si nous on
pense que c'est comme ça que le flagel
bactérien évolué vous n'en rencontrerez
jamais évidemment que les
évolutionnistes ne sont pas con à ce
point là
on a besoin d'autres mécanismes qui
régulent le montage de ces structures
des mécanismes qui eux-mêmes dépendent
d'autres mécanismes pour leur assemblage
si un seul de ces éléments venait à
manquer ou été mal placé le moteur ne
fonctionnerait pas le dispositif qui
permet de construire le moteur
flagellaire et donc lui aussi
irréductiblement complexe en fait on
rencontre ici une complexité
irréductible tout au long de la chaîne
winner
ne devrait pas exister
nous avons encore beaucoup si on avait
raison le flagel bactérien n'existerait
pas
à part tout ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure
d'une succession de nombreuses et je
vous laisse réfléchir sur la pertinence
de citer quelqu'un qui a travaillé sur
un sujet scientifique qui a 150 ans
faut vraiment être d'une malhonnêteté
intellectuelle phénoménale
absolument phénoménal pour citer un
chercheur qui a travaillé il y a 150 ans
en disant eh regardez il a dit ça il y a
150 ans c'est forcément que ça théorie
était fausse
ceci dit Charles Darwin a fait a fait
ici montre d'honnêteté intellectuelle en
disant ça donc pour son époque
contrairement aux gens qui ont réalisé
ce documentaire
à l'honnêteté intellectuelle depuis tout
à l'heure elle a foutu le camp mais
deuxièmement comment la vie elle-même
est apparue sur Terre on sait bah les
yeux les yeux à l'époque ils auraient pu
tout à fait bien le savoir parce que
comme je l'ai dit dans la biodiversité
actuelle on a à peu près toutes les
différentes étapes enfin on a toutes les
différentes stades de perfectionnement
qu'un œil peut avoir depuis comme je
l'ai dit la simple cellule
photoréceptrice jusqu'à l'oeil des
vertébrés modernes
donc malhonnêteté intellectuelle la
voici la voilà et donc les ailes on a
pareil aujourd'hui des très très beau
scénarios évolutif avec justement la
préadaptation
la préadaptation des des
bras des dinosaures théropodes qui sont
petit à petit devenus des ailes d'abord
parce que les plumes étaient utilisées
surtout à des fins de thermorégulation
puis pourquoi pas à des fins de de
parade sexuelle et d'aérodynamisme
pendant la course jusqu'à l'utilisation
pour le vol
et ceci étant dit comment vous
créationniste expliquez-vous le fait que
il y ait des oiseaux qui ont des ailes
pour voler mais ne veulent pas comme les
autres ruches
pourquoi le grand créateur le grand
horloger dans son infini sagesse et son
cahier des charges normalement
divin pourquoi ce grand horloger
s'est-il emmerdé à filer des ailes à des
animaux qui ne volent pas
vous avez deux heures
[Musique]
de la vie sur Terre à une grande
arborescence
à la base on retrouve ceci n'est pas
l'arbre que Charles Darwin a dessiné
il y a effectivement un arbre
phylogénétique dans le dans le livre de
Darwin mais ce n'est pas cet arbre là
grande diversité de végétale et animale
que l'on observe aujourd'hui sur terre
de l'arborescence de la première cellule
vivante Darwin n'a pas dit grand-chose
en fait dans l'origine des espèces il
n'a même pas abordé la question de
l'origine de la vie à partir d'une
matière non vivante oui parce que c'est
pas ça qu'il essaie d'expliquer il
explique l'origine de la biodiversité
pas l'origine de la vie comme je l'ai
expliqué encore une fois au début
est-ce que c'est dramatique un orage
nous pouvions en présence de toutes
sortes de celle d'ammoniaques et d'acide
de lumière de chaleur d'électricité
qu'un composé de protéines fût
chimiquement formée près a subir des
changements encore plus complexes
bonjour aujourd'hui une telle matière
serait instantanément dévorée peut-être
qu'avant l'apparition des créatures
vivantes cela n'aurait pas été le cas
au cours des dernières années de sa vie
Darwin développa ce qui vient de décrire
finalement c'est plus ou moins ce qu'on
a appelé plus tard l'expérience de 1000
heures on a mis tout un tas de composés
bien biochimiques dans de l'eau chaude
balancer de l'électricité là-dedans
jusqu'à ce qu'on apparaisse des acides
aminés expérience de Miller qui a été
pétée et répété jusque dans les années
récentes je veux dire on n'arrête pas de
répéter différentes versions de
l'expérience de Miller vous imaginez
bien qu'on sait pas arrêter dans les
années 50 avec Miller donc on l'a répété
des milliers de fois et on a fini par
créer plein d'acides aminés certains
utilisent à la vie d'autres non et on a
fini par créer même des nucléotides dans
cette expérience de Miller mais comme
j'ai dit de toute façon on n'a pas
besoin de l'expérience de Miller pour
expliquer l'origine des nucléotides et
des acides aminés puisque on a la preuve
qu'ils apparaissent spontanément dans
les météorites de toute façon
donc même même sans l'expérience de 1000
heures on s'en sort bien donc là s'il
passe le prochain quart d'heure à parler
de l'expérience de Miller va y avoir un
cut dans la vidéo parce que ça fait déjà
très longtemps que je parle
composition chimiques dans les eaux
primitives de la terre
mais dans les années 20 et 30 à savon
russe du nom d'Alexandre au Paris
formula une théorique détaillée sur la
possibilité de ce phénomène il appela
l'évolution chimique
de la vie à partir des principes
darwiniens il a imaginé le simple
composé chimique ce combinant plusieurs
fois pour former des molécules plus
grandes puis ces molécules se seraient
organisées à l'aide de variations
aléatoire et de la sélection naturelle
pour donner lieu à la première cellule
vivante primitive
pendant les 30 ans qui suivirent de
nombreux scientifiques cherchèrent à
développer et affiner ses idées en se
penchant sur les questions soulevées par
opparine et Darwin comment la vie
avait-elle pu émerger de simples
produits chimiques
un homme pensait avoir trouvé la
solution
biologiques m'a très longtemps passionné
par son envergure et son importance
d'où venons-nous pourquoi sommes-nous là
des questions qui m'interpellaient du
point de vue scientifique
des années 60 jusqu'au début des années
80 était l'un des théoriciens les plus
avancés au monde dans le domaine de
l'évolution chimique comme d'autres
savants il essayait d'expliquer comment
la vie sur Terre était apparue à partir
d'un processus purement naturel en 1969
canyon coécrivait un ouvrage important
sur l'origine de la vie
[Applaudissements]
et moi-même
pension qu'en réunissant toutes les
preuves empiriques accumulées du milieu
à la fin des années 60
nous aurions de fortes chances
d'expliquer l'origine des principaux
éléments ayant abouti à la vie
[Musique]
j'ai du mal à comprendre comment ce truc
arrive à convaincre qui que ce soit
enfin
c'est là on essaye donc de nous montrer
que un savant russe des années 30 à tort
en nous citant un savant américain des
années 60
avec tout ce que ça implique de
possibles concurrence politique parce
que les années 60 c'est la guerre froide
je le rappelle c'est la guerre froide
mais
solide quand même c'est la bonne guerre
froide qui a failli dégénérer en guerre
mondiale nucléaire en l'occurrence donc
j'aimerais bien savoir à quel moment les
gens s'arrêtent en disant ah dis donc il
a raison ce mec et en plus là ils ont
même pas cité l'expérience de Miller
c'est encore pire que ce que je croyais
c'est à dire que au lieu de citer
l'expérience que n'importe quelle
personne sensée devrait citer en plus il
si de ce chercheur
moi personnellement j'en ai jamais
entendu parler
mais encore une fois je contrairement à
eux je vais pas confondre ma propre
ignorance avec une ignorance générale
[Musique]
en de multiples fonctions dans la
cellule dans les années 60 déjà dans les
années 60 du coup ça aurait été très
très malhonnête de dire qu'on avait
aucune idée de où venait les protéines
puisque l'expérience de Miller avait
réussi à générer des acides aminés qui
elle-même sont les briques de base des
protéines donc si ils s'apprête là
maintenant à dire on n'a aucune [ __ ]
d'idées d'où sortent les protéines
malhonnêteté intellectuelle
[Musique]
je vous invite à vous arrêter maintenant
sur le charabia qui vient de vous
balancer aucun effort de vulgarisation
digne de ce nom ne le ferait si ce
n'était pas pour essayer de vous
impressionner avec du gros baratin
scientifique
c'est vous vous rappelez on essaye de
vous convaincre de la complexité
incroyable de du vivant on essaye pas du
tout de vous convaincre que si c'était
moi qui devait vous expliquer ça je vous
expliquerai que les acides aminés c'est
jamais que des assemblages de molécules
qui est de molécules qui elle-même
existe ailleurs à l'état naturel
ça a rien de chimiquement si compliqué
que ça mais bref
que la chimie du vivant n'est finalement
qu'une extension de la biochimie non
vivante
et c'est ça l'argument principal pour
dire que la vie est d'origine non
vivante c'est parce que la biochimie du
vivant n'est jamais qu'une extension de
la biochimie du non-vivant
il n'y a pas de mur solide entre de la
chimie du vivant et de la chimie du non
vivant c'est pas vrai c'est un mensonge
si on vous l'a fait croire
mais évidemment là on préfère vous
convaincre que la complexité est
irréductible et donc qu'est-ce qu'on
fait bah on vous bazarde du vocabulaire
scientifique dans ta tronche sorti par
une autorité scientifique ou du moins ce
que les ce que ce documentaire veut
faire passer pour une autorité
scientifique
et du coup bah à part à part ta gueule
et en caisse et bah vous avez pas le
choix
waouh il a l'air de connaître il a l'air
de savoir ce qu'il dit le monsieur en
blouse blanche waouh
dans la cellule sauf le stockage la
formation génétique effectuée par l'ADN
et la RN toutes les fonctions
quotidiennes telles que le nettoyage de
la cellule et la production d'énergie
sont accomplies par les protéines
aurait été aussi indispensables au
premier organisme vivant quelles leçons
dans les cellules aujourd'hui ils
reconnaissait aussi la complexité de
leur construction
dans la complexité de la cellule là dont
il vous parle il a il a parlé de la
génération d'énergie c'est certes des
protéines qui les font des protéines des
mitochondries
c'est même encore mieux que ça en
réalité c'est qu'en fait la plupart des
protéines qui étaient à la base
faite par les mitochondries fabriqués
par les mitochondries on maintenant les
gènes qui codent pour ces protéines sont
maintenant intégrées au génome de la
cellule qui les contient donc notre
génome à nous en l'occurrence donc en
fait il y a eu des transferts de gènes
entre le génome de la mitochondrie
jusqu'à notre génome à nous c'est Gênes
ce sont des gènes bactériens à la base
quand on séquence ces gènes et qu'on les
compare à des protéos bactéries donc des
bactéries qui vivent là comme ça autour
de nous ce sont les mêmes
c'est pareil je sais pas comment un
créationniste serait concilier avec ça
c'est tout encore une fois tout se passe
comme si
ces bactéries faisaient leur vie dehors
et ont ensuite été absorbés par d'autres
organismes et petit à petit
graduellement
très graduellement ces gènes ont été
transférés de la bactérie donc de la
mitochondrie maintenant devenu une
mitochondrie à la cellule qui l'a
absorbé
comment il réconcilie ça avec une vision
créationniste du monde je ne le sais pas
pourquoi est-ce que un grand horloger
s'emmerderait à créer une cellule
carriotte d'un côté une bactérie de
l'autre poussée de son ensuite pour
ensuite pousser de son gros doigt
magique cette bactérie à l'intérieur
d'une cellule eucaryote pour ensuite
encore une fois pousser de son gros
doigt magique un par un les gènes de
cette nouvelle mitochondrie dans le
génome de la cellule eucaryote
comment vous expliquer ça le dessin
intelligent
c'est pas intelligent du tout c'est
grotesque Mans stupidement compliqué
enfin c'est grotesquements stupidement
et surtout inutilement compliqué pour un
dessin intelligent
alors que le scénario évolutif il est
quand même vachement plus simple
endosymbiose il a essayé de le bouffer
et puis la bactérie qui s'est faite
bouffer au bout d'un moment par
sélection naturelle il y en a qui ont
fini par survivre en balançant de
l'énergie qui apprend à prendre
l'énergie mais il me digère pas voilà
pour l'énergie et me digère pas d'accord
ok je te dis gère pas et je prends ton
énergie
la bactérie elle était quand même à
l'abri parce que elle est quand même
protégée à l'intérieur d'une autre
cellule donc elle risque pas de se faire
bouffer par autre chose pendant ce
temps-là pendant qu'elle arrive à
survivre dans cette autre cellule qui la
protège
et puis génération après génération
graduellement
la bactérie qui s'était faite bouffer
par la cellule caryotte a refilé ses
gènes par transfert horizontal à la
cellule eucaryote parce que de toute
façon elle avait plus besoin de
s'emmerder à faire ça elle-même puisque
la cellule eucaryote quoi qu'il arrive
elle va
elle va s'occuper de produire ces
protéines pour elle pourquoi s'emmerder
à les protéger allez produire soi-même
donc voilà tiens prends mes gènes prends
mes gènes moi j'en ai marre de les
traduire moi-même ça fait chier ça me
coûte de l'énergie et je survis parce
que je te produit de l'énergie donc
produit des toi-même
ça c'est le scénario évolutionniste
ultra simplifié pour les demeurer mais
c'est comme ça que je l'ai compris donc
c'est un scénario pour demeurer voilà
mais que les choses soient claires c'est
quand même vachement plus satisfaisant
que de se dire il y a un gros doigt
intelligent qui a fait un truc inutile
pour pour ensuite l'annuler deux minutes
après quoi
bref
mitochondries parce que ça fait chier
les critiques ça fait chier les
créationsnistes les mitochondries
c'est de la complexité inutile encore
une fois
c'est un autre bel exemple d'ailleurs
les mitochondries de complexité inutile
c'est
inutilement compliqué d'avoir une
organite cellulaire qui est spécialement
dédié à la production d'énergie avec les
gènes de cette organite cellulaire
produit ailleurs
dans le noyau de la cellule de la
cellule haute c'est stupidement
inutilement compliqué
et ça s'explique très bien évolutivement
mais encore une fois et pourquoi cet
organite aurait des gènes qui
correspondent à des protéos bactériques
qui viennent d'ailleurs même problème
pour les pinsons de bah oui il n'y a pas
de raison pour laquelle un organite
cellulaire créé spécialement pour
générer de l'énergie il n'y a pas de
raison que l'ADN de cette organisme
cellulaire ressemble à un autre
organisme qui vit dehors comme ça tout
seul et qui fait ça life une petite
Protéo bactérie comme ça là dans le coin
là
ça c'est les grandes questions que les
créationnistes refusent d'aborder parce
que ça les emmerde
alors que là toutes les questions là qui
qui sont en train de nous montrer et qui
soi-disant devraient emmerder les
évolutionnistes bah comme je vous le dit
depuis tout à l'heure Richard dokkins et
Stephen Gould les ont abordés il y a
très longtemps déjà et on a aucun
problème à les intégrer à la théorie de
l'évolution
naires
on est parti du moteur bactérien comme
cette anneau sont composés d'une seule
[Musique]
protection
des protéines
plus petites appelées acides aminés
relier les unes aux autres pour former
de longues chaînes
un très grand degré de complexité dans
l'architecture
des protéines
dans la nature vintage examiner servent
à la construction de ces chaînes de
protéines les biologistes les ont
comparés au 26 lettres de l'alphabet
les lettres sont disposées correctement
on obtient un texte compréhensible sinon
on crée du charabia
le même principe est-ce que une série
d'acide aminés est capable de
s'assembler toute seule sans l'être sans
l'aide
d'une machinerie cellulaire afin de
former
une protéine je me demande si on
n'aurait pas éventuellement déjà parler
de ça sur la chaîne dans une vidéo qui
s'appelle la biogenèse
hop dans la vidéo sur la biogenèse que
je vous invite à voir
alors là c'est catalyser ah c'est la non
c'est la formation d'ARN pardon là qui
est catalysé par la montmorionite
donc là c'est même pas c'est même pas
les acides aminés c'est l'ARN et qui se
forme non pas donc contrairement à celui
dont je vous ai montré tout à l'heure
qui disait les ARN peuvent s'assembler
sur la sur le
sur la glace la glace le vert volcanique
non il y a aussi un argile qui s'appelle
la montmorillonite qui est capable de
catalyser la formation de molécules
proche de l'ARN donc ils vont nous
parler de la complexité de l'ADN dans
pas longtemps c'est là que ça va revenir
voilà donc ça se forme spontanément
donc les expériences de Miller qui ont
réussi à produire des acides aminés
et qui sont capables aussi de produire
du coût des assemblages de protéines
et pour ce qui est des protéines et de
leur géométrie en 3D elle est en partie
due aux histoes certes mais elle est
aussi en partie enfin et en partie du à
d'autres protéines qu'on appelle les
histores mais elle aussi en partie
complètement spontanée du simplement
propriété chimiques des composantes
qu'il est forment donc les acides aminés
au propriétaire chimiques et physique de
ces acides aminés donc pareil la
complexité de la structure d'une
protéine c'est pas non plus complètement
impossible à comprendre je veux dire les
protéines ne formeraient pas
spontanément des genres de ligne droite
de d'acide aminés ils auraient une
structure 3D qui serait déjà considérée
comme complexe de toute façon donc on
n'est pas non plus sur du mystère plus
plus la structure 3D des protéines c'est
pas non plus un gros gros mystère
qui s'applique aux acides aminés et aux
protéines
il existe plus de 30 000 protéines
distinctes et chacune d'elles reposent
sur une combinaison différente on essaye
de vous faire croire que
les acides aminés s'aligneraient comme
ça
alors qu'en fait non ça formerait pas
des lignes
cette pliure elle aurait lieu alors elle
est supplémentée par des histones qui
vont donner une architecture comme il
dit
une architecture mieux contrôlée mais
ces protéines n'auraient de toute façon
pas une forme linéaire
sans ça
en plus il évoque même pas les histoires
c'est faux que je leur apprenne en plus
[Musique]
argument du faux dilemme
soit c'est magique soit ça marche pas
[Musique]
des découvertes sur la structure des
protéines ont poussé les biologistes
assemblés ce mystère pour remarquer
comme l'évocation des années 50 et 60 et
récurrente comme je le disent ça ils ne
se sont pas renouvelés depuis ce
documentaire il date des années fin 80
début 90 ils n'ont pas renouvelé leurs
arguments depuis les années 50-60
se base sur des bouquins qui sont qui
étaient déjà vieux à l'époque où le
documentaire a été fait quoi
imaginez bien que la biochimie des
années 60 c'était c'était primitive
comparé à ce que c'était devenu dans les
années 90 quoi ça fait partie de ces
champs de recherche
qui ont qui se sont sûrs développés
pendant les années 80
vous imaginez aujourd'hui
imaginez aujourd'hui un informat
imaginez qu'il y ait des gens qui
veulent pas croire que les ordinateurs
ça marche et qui se base sur les travaux
d'Alan Turing pour dire mais regarde ça
devrait pas marcher
c'est quand même le travail fondateur de
l'informatique moderne et ça devrait pas
marcher
c'est ridicule c'est ridicule les mecs
ils seraient là à te montrer Alan Turing
là des photos d'Alan Turing comme il
vous montre les photos de Charles Darwin
là il serait là à vous montrer des
photos d'Alan Turing en vous disant
regardez c'est le saint
dessinuring le grand prophète de
l'informatique et il a écrit des
conneries
puis il vous montre là et puis vous
montrerez un ordinateur moderne et vous
dirait mais regardez c'est trop complexe
et puis regardez dans les années 60 ils
ont dit à un ordinateur complexe comme
ça ça devrait pas pouvoir exister c'est
beaucoup trop complexe
mais c'était déjà ouais dans les années
80-85 80 début 90 même on a même en
étant généreux sur l'âge de cette vidéo
c'était déjà obsolète tout ce qui
racontait comme je l'ai dit ça avait
déjà été des banquets de toute façon des
milliers de fois
tout simplement par la chimie
beaucoup de fatigue je fatigue
[Musique]
c'est au cours de cette période que mes
doutes sur certains aspects de la pensée
évolutionniste se sont manifestés j'ai
été confronté à un contre argument
solide de la part d'un de mes étudiants
vas-y le contraire de moche
était tenue d'expliquer comment les
premières protéines avaient pu être
assemblés sans l'aide d'instruction
génétique aujourd'hui dans les cellules
vivantes les chaînes va s'examiner ne se
font pas directement par des forces
d'attraction entre leurs éléments
scénarios des origines envisagés par
Canyon
une grosse molécule à l'intérieur de la
cellule qui contient les instructions
d'assemblage d'acides aminés en
protéines il s'agit de l'ADN
croyait que les protéines auraient pu se
former directement sans les instructions
de l'ADN et c'est ce qui crée à
l'enthousiasme scientifique autour de sa
théorie mais plus il étudiant les
propriétés des Acides Animés et des
protéines plus il douta que les
protéines aient pu s'assembler sans AD
bon bah maintenant on sait d'où il vient
l'ADN puisque je vous ai déjà montré le
en tractusian enfin le Paléo news où on
vous dit d'où vient l'ADN les
polyribonucléides les acides
polyribonucléiques les
polyribonucléotides
on a de très solides idées sur d'où ils
viennent ils les nucléotides peuvent se
former dans l'espace on le sait dans le
vide spatial le milieu le plus hostile à
la vie il n'y a pas de raison qu'ils
aient été créés là pour ensuite
s'assembler ailleurs encore une fois le
créationnistes ils sont ils sont
complètement à la ramasse sur cet
argument là pourquoi créer des
nucléotides dans les météorites pour
ensuite le doigt magique les envois sur
la terre s'écraser pour ensuite le doigt
magique assemble les acides nucléiques
non c'est c'est tout ça se fait
spontanément parce que encore une fois
on parle d'un phénomène qui serait
autrement
inutilement complexe pour aboutir à un
résultat qui serait tellement facile à
accomplir avec un doigt magique
donc là on a donc de la complexité
inutile ça apparaît dans l'espace ça
s'assemble soit dans l'espace soit sur
terre et ça surtout les
polyribonucléotides ça sent peuvent
s'assembler sur les surfaces glacées
enfin les surfaces pas glacées les
surfaces volcaniques ou sur les surfaces
couvertes de montmorillonite comme je
vous l'avais montré dans cet article là
donc les argiles montmory ioniques donc
il y a pas de il y a pas de mystère
enfin il y a plus de mystère je veux
bien reconnaître qu'à l'époque il y
avait un mystère mais aujourd'hui il y a
tellement de mystères on a donc on n'a
pas si vous voulez les créationnistes
pourront toujours vous rétorquer encore
une fois que oui mais ça n'a pas formé
de vrai ADN pour l'instant
non je suis d'accord ça n'a pas formé de
vrai ADN mais en face à dune ça donne
quand même une idée assez solide de
comment ça a pu se former vers c'est
juste qu'on n'a pas on a juste pas le
loisir le luxe des centaines de
centaines de millions d'années qu'a eu
la vie pour apparaître à l'origine de la
terre on a juste le temps de quelques
vies humaines pour comprendre ce qui
s'est passé en plusieurs centaines de
millions d'années d'une
et de deux
créationnistes tu ne peux pas dire mieux
tu peux pas expliquer mieux encore une
fois c'est stupidement
inutilement compliqué
pourquoi est-ce que le gros doigt
magique créerait des nucléotides dans le
videospatial
parce que le vide spatial c'est le
milieu le plus hostile du monde donc
s'il est venu cléothyde sont capables
d'apparaître dans le videospatial j'ai
dit tout à l'heure ça pouvait en ce
moment c'est la terre mais en réalité ça
peut apparaître sur terre aussi le vidéo
spatial c'est quand même le truc le plus
hostile possible sur terre c'était
certainement moins hostile que dans le
videospatial donc les nucléotides s'ils
peuvent s'assembler dans le videospatial
ils peuvent s'assembler sur terre et
s'il y avait et si nucléotide plus
basalte ou nucléotide plus argile sa
forme des acides des assemblages de
polyn de nucléotides donc du proto ADN
j'ai pas besoin de d'une grosse
hypothèse pour dire qu'un jour ça a pu
faire de l'ADN ceci étant dit ça
sous-entend que l'ADN a du préexister à
tout le reste ce qui n'est même pas
forcément le cas et c'est là que
intervient la théorie du monde ARN ce
que j'explique dans la vidéo sur la
biogénèse le monde ARN ou en fait l'ARN
a précédé et l'ADN et les protéines
parce que l'ARN est capable de s'auto
répliquer enfin il est capable de se
répliquer tout seul
et il est capable d'agir comme une
protéine donc il a finalement l'avantage
des demandes l'avantage du monde
protéique l'avantage du monde nucléique
donc l'ARN on pense qu'à un moment il y
a un ARN ou du moins un truc qui devait
ressembler à de l'ARN ou se comporter
relativement de la même façon qui a
précédé cette division fondamentale
entre l'ADN d'un côté qui remplit une
pure fonction de codage et la protéines
qui remplissent une pure fonction
physiologique l'ARN est capable
d'accomplir les deux et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on aurait une phase de
transcription
d'ADN ARN et d'ARN enfin messager en
l'occurrence et d'ARN à protéines parce
que cet ARN c'est le fameux
échafaudage qu'il y a entre ces deux
structures irréductiblement complexes
oui on n'est pas complètement sans
hypothèse après oui on manque de preuves
ça je suis d'accord mais enfin à moi
d'envoyer une caméra dans le passé pour
voir ce qui s'y est passé et encore il
faudrait même pas une caméra en
l'occurrence il faudrait
il faudrait vraiment du matos de ouf
dans le passé avec une machine à
remonter dans le temps pour le voir
s'accomplir sur des plusieurs millions
d'années ça j'avoue on manque de preuve
mais enfin on a quand même un faisceau
d'indices assez ouf qui pointe dans une
direction donnée
exactement ce que je présente
dans ce graph là
c'est qu'on a un faisceau de présomption
qui pointe dans une direction donnée on
a des points
et alors après tu peux proposer un
scénario raisonnable ce que je viens de
vous dire qui relie ces points
exactement de cette façon là de façon le
plus direct possible ou alors tu peux
proposer un scénario complètement pété
qui zigzag entre les points et qui fait
intervenir des gros doigts magiques
c'est à toi de voir si tu veux faire de
la science ou du n'importe quoi j'ai
envie de dire
avec l'ADN canyon fut confronté à une
molécule possédant des propriétés qui ne
pouvaient pas expliquer par le biais des
processus naturels en effet une mine
d'information se trouve fermement
verrouillée dans sa structure en double
hélice sous la forme de composés
chimiques spécifiquement séquencés que
les scientifiques représentent par les
lettres a.c.t et g dans une langue
écrite l'information est transmise au
moyen d'un arrangement spécifique de
l'être
de la même manière les instructions
nécessaires à l'assemblage des acides
aminés en protéines sont transmises par
des séquences d'éléments chimiques
disposer le long de l'axe de l'ADN ce
code chimique a été surnommé le langage
de la vie
il s'agit de l'assemblage d'informations
le plus dense et le plus élaboré que
l'on connaisse dans l'univers
on n'a toujours pas parlé de
l'expérience de Miller d'ailleurs pas
ses sous silence mais alors comme un mal
propre
ou démontré que les protéines avaient
été directement fabriquées par les
acides aminés et sans ADN dans les
océans primitifs finalement il s'est
rendu compte qu'il ne pouvait faire ni
la ni l'autre
mais depuis on s'est rendu compte qu'il
y avait la RN ARN dont il ne nous
parlerons pas l'ARN a des propriétés à
la fois des protéines et de l'ADN
dans un petit volume au sud
microscopique d'océan primitif
et centaines de composés moléculaires
nécessaires à l'émergence d'un cycle
tour répliquant est un problème énorme
et c'est ainsi que mes doutes sur la
capacité des acides aminés à s'organiser
en séquence biologique indépendantes et
fonctionnelles sans la présence
préalable d'informations génétique vont
conduite à un point de rupture
intellectuel vers la fin des années 70
un point de rupture intellectuelle je
suis devenu créationniste c'est un gros
point de rupture intellectuelle
aurait pu se regrouper en protéines
[Musique]
quelque temps au centre vous pariez
combien que l'ARN va être complètement
passé sous silence
vous pariez combien
non elle doit être catalysée mais pas
forcément par des histones ou de l'ARN
ou ce que tu veux
il y a des il y a des éléments minéraux
qui sont capables d'aider catalyser
l'assemblage des protéines exactement
comme le vert volcanique et la momie
ionite catalyse l'assemblage des
nucléotides
à savoir l'origine de l'information
génétique elle-même j'ai été amené à
reconsidérer ma position sur les
origines
pour dim canyon une nouvelle question
occupa le centre de ses recherches sur
l'origine de la vie quelle est la source
des informations biologiques contenues
dans l'ADN
c'est quelqu'un pouvait déceler
l'origine de ces messages encoder dans
l'être vivant on aboutirait à une
satisfaction intellectuelle bien plus
grande que celle offerte par la théorie
de l'évolution chimique
il dit qu'il voit pas le rapport
c'est c'est très élégant ce qui vient de
dire c'est très compliqué c'est très
scientifique enfin ça en a l'air mais en
réalité ça veut rien dire
[Musique]
simple fait du hasard mais arrêtez de
parler de hasard vous savez même pas ce
que vous dites
de Scrabble sur une table
[Musique]
deux lignes de Shakespeare en laissant
tomber des ou même le l'oeuvre entière
de Shakespeare le fait que encore une
fois tu négliges totalement
les milliers d'années d'évolution
culturelle qui ont amené à d'une part
l'invention de l'écriture d'autre part
l'invention de la littérature puisque
l'écriture n'a pas été inventée pour
écrire de la littérature mais bien pour
écrire d'abord des livres de contes donc
invention de l'écriture invention de la
littérature puis démocratisation de
cette littérature puis démocratisation
de la dramaturgie pendant
enfin tu négliges encore une fois des
milliers d'années d'évolution culturelle
qui ont conduit un jour à la naissance
d'un homme qui allait recevoir les
produits de cette éducation
et aller conduire à l'assemblage de ces
lettres pour former une oeuvre de
Shakespeare ou la totalité des oeuvres
de Shakespeare sachant que on n'est même
pas sûr que Shakespeare soit l'auteur de
tout son ouvrage même si je ne suis pas
un spécialiste pour être tout à fait
honnête mais
voilà
donc encore une fois on va confondre un
autre des arguments créationnistes c'est
la confusion entre ontogénie et
phylogénie on confond l'évolution au
sens darwinien avec l'évolution sans se
Pokémon
considérer que les instructions
génétiques nécessaires à la composition
des protéines dans l'organisme
unicellulaire le plus simple remplirait
des centaines de pages de textes
imprimés
et encore une fois conclusion l'ADN ne
peut pas exister
plutôt que la sélection naturelle sur
des variations aléatoires parmi les
composés chimiques pour produire la
première forme de vie mais ces
propositions possède un problème
et naturelle ne pouvait se manifester
qu'après l'apparition de la première
cellule vivante
c'est faux
la sélection naturelle s'applique à
partir du moment où il y a
reproduction parce qu'à partir du moment
où il y a reproduction il y a
descendance
et comme aucune reproduction n'est
absolument parfaite il y a forcément
descendance avec modification donc il
n'est pas obligé d'y avoir une cellule
vivante
donc sous-entendu Lucas de Last
Universal commandant de ses stores il
existe il est Lucas était probablement
séparé du premier truc auto reproducteur
par plusieurs millions d'années pendant
lesquels la sélection naturelle s'est
opérée sur ce truc qui était capable de
s'auto-répler cette molécule quand je
dis truc c'est une molécule à base de
carbone capable de s'autorer et on sait
par ailleurs
que certaines molécules à base de
carbone tels que le graphite sont
capables de s'auto-répiquer j'en parlais
aussi dans la vidéo sur la biogénèse
donc des autres des molécules
auto-réplantes à base de carbone
mais non vivante
au moins en théorie ça existe et en
pratique ça a pu être observé
et encore une fois ça a été déjà cité
comme un contre-argument par Richard
dokkins dans son livre l'horloger
aveugle
qui date des années 70 donc un
pardonnable de encore citer ça comme un
argument plausible dans une vidéo qui
date des années fin 80 début
90mes capables de se répliquer des
cellules d'ADN pas forcément des
organismes n'importe quoi qui se
reproduit et susceptibles de sélection
naturelle même notamment les virus
informatiques
les virus informatiques il y a une
sélection naturelle qui s'applique sur
eux tout ce qui est capable de se
reproduire fait l'objet de sélection
naturelle
il y avait même une théorie comme quoi
une théorie sur les multivers
ou les multivers capables de générer de
nouveaux multivers serait plus nombreux
que les multivers qui ne sont pas
capables en générer simplement parce
qu'ils se reproduisent mieux donc par
sélection naturelle
ces capillotracté comme théorie mais si
vous voulez la sélection naturelle en
théorie c'est juste un phénomène de
sélection qui est naturel c'est un
phénomène
de destruction non aléatoire
c'est ça la sélection naturelle c'est
pas la sélection naturelle c'est pas une
petite fée bleue qui se balade avec une
baguette en disant toi tu es mort toi tu
es mort toi tu es mort toi tu es mort
pas personnifié là sélection naturelle
et c'est pas spécifiquement dirigé vers
les organismes vivants n'importe quoi
qui se reproduit est susceptible
de passer par le filtre d'une
destruction non aléatoire
la reproduction étant un phénomène clé
aussi dans ce phénomène si tu es capable
de te reproduire plus vite que tu te
fais des mots lire
tu te maintiens en tout cas tes
descendants vont se maintenir
donc en plus du fait qu'ils font une
focalisation sur la sélection naturelle
il y a une non compréhension de ce
qu'est la sélection naturelle qui est
assez foudroyant fulgurante et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas de sélection naturelle
vous expliquer pourquoi l'autorisation
existe très bien sans ADN on n'est pas
donc pas à utiliser la sélection un
virus informatique n'a pas d'ADN par
exemple
et pourtant il se réplique
[Musique]
les prions
les prions n'ont pas d'ADN et pourtant
il se reproduisent bon d'accord il
parasite une autre cellule mais quand
même
mais quand même
pas été en mesure de définir l'origine
de l'information génétique canyon
n'avait plus qu'une alternative le gros
doigt magique
je comprends pas comment ça marche c'est
forcément le gros doigt magique
c'est la seule alternative que je vois
tout c'est pas net si j'ai pas compris
comment ça marche c'est forcément le
gros doigt magique
elligente
impressionnant
les images de synthèse nous permettent
d'entrer dans une cellule et d'observer
son remarquablement
me permettre de d'inventer comment ça
fonctionne
[Musique]
au coeur de la cellule on aperçoit les
bras compacts des entrepôts
d'information indispensables à la
construction de toutes les protéines
d'un organisme
moi convaincre à quel point c'est beau
c'est compliqué youpi on a déjà bien
moi je suis fatigué là j'en peux plus on
accélère
pour former une molécule appelée ARN
messager une autre règle de des Bunka
j'ai pénitence
c'est que je dois tout me farcir de A à
Z
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
éroïde le processus du décodage commence
mais vous voyez là ce qu'ils viennent de
décrire c'est exactement ce que
j'appelais de la complexité inutile
pourquoi les ribosomes viennent pas se
[ __ ] directement sur la DN
alors on m'a répondu bah oui mais les
ribosomes ils risquent d'endommager
l'ADN ou bien les ribosomes sont pas
compatibles avec l'ADN je sais pas quoi
mais je m'en fous en fait
si c'était conçu intelligemment ça
devrait être possible tu vois ce que je
veux dire si pourquoi est-ce qu'on est
obligé de passer par une phase ARN
messager pour sortir du noyau pourquoi
pourquoi c'est pas les ribosomes qui
rentrent dans le noyau ou qui sont à la
surface du noyau l'ADN vient se coller
au ribosome et puis ça transcrit tu vois
et ça traduit directement au lieu de
transcrire d'abord et de traduire
ensuite
c'est de la complexité inutile qu'on
explique très bien par le scénario que
je vous ai donné tout à l'heure ou l'ARN
sert finalement de d'échafaudage
à l'apparition et de l'ADN d'à côté et
des protéines de l'autre et que du coup
bah ce le fait qu'il y a encore de l'ARN
notamment messager entre autres il y en
a d'autres des types d'ARN mais le fait
qu'il y ait de l'ARN messager du coup
serait en fait une cicatrice de cet
échafaudage cicatrice évolutive mais là
ce que vous ce qui sont en train de vous
répondre de vous présenter en fait c'est
un exemple typique de cette complexité
qu'il considère comme irréductible alors
qu'en fait si elle est hyper réductible
cette complexité au contraire faudrait
la tailler un peu
dans un monde où c'était bien ou ce
serait bien conçu on passerait
directement de l'ADN aux protéines sans
passer par la RN mais ce n'est pas bien
conçu parce que ça n'a pas été conçu du
tout
[Musique]
spécifiquement
des centaines leur disposition
séquentielle
non on essaie juste de vous convaincre
que c'est trop compliqué pour être pour
pas être magique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a aucun il y a aucun
c'est formidable comme il vient de vous
dire regardez ça porte la marque d'une
conception intelligente ah bon ou
moi je veux dire à part si tu me montres
écrit Dieu l'a fait écrit quelque part
je vois pas je ne vois pas du tout j'ai
peut-être confondu les histoires avec
autre chose mais c'est de la simple
curiosité
[Musique]
les biologistes doivent constamment se
rappeler les que ce qu'il voit n'est pas
le fruit
ah bah oui mais tu me laisses pas le
temps de dire
c'est quoi les biologistes doivent
constamment se rappeler que ce qu'il
voit ne pas le fruit d'une conception
mais d'une évolution
[Musique]
qui a découvert l'ADN
la question qui vient de se poser je
vais remettre en lecture un 25 parce que
là c'est un peu dur à suivre mais en
gros la question qui vient de se poser
c'est est-il possible que ce soit issu
d'une conception intelligente et c'est
là où justement comme je le disais la
voiture et eux qui se ramènent avec une
roue de vélo en disant hey est-il
possible que cette roue de vélo aille
quelque part dans ta voiture qui roule
déjà très bien toute seule c'est la
question à les poser à l'envers en
réalité c'est il faudrait déjà que tes
preuves de l'existence de cette
intelligence avant de te dire est-ce que
cette intelligence il serait pour
quelque chose dans le fonctionnement de
cette voiture si t'as pas la preuve de
l'existence de cette intelligence
d'abord la preuve scientifique j'entends
pas seulement la conviction intime que
cette intelligence existe
la conviction intime mais complètement
indémontrable scientifiquement j'entends
immatériel que cette intelligence existe
bah ta roue de vélo tu te la gardes et
la voiture elle roule très bien toute
seule donc là ce qui vient de se poser
comme question c'est est-ce que cette
route de vélo elle va quelque part sur
la voiture il m'a répondu en tant
qu'évolutionniste et non ma voiture ma
théorie de l'évolution roule très bien
toute seule
donc c'est la question il retourne
complètement en fait le la logique
[Musique]
non on va considérer les plus simples
d'abord les plus simples
oui alors le problème de la théorie de
l'évolution de Darwin c'est qu'à
l'écarte une cause possible à
l'évolution cette cause étant Dieu le
gros doigt magique
sauf que si vous vous mettez à
considérer l'existence du gros doigt
magique comme une possible cause de
l'évolution le problème c'est qu'avec
cette même logique il va falloir
considérer la possibilité
que ce soit pas Dieu le qui soit
derrière ce mécanisme mais une licorne
la grande licorne rose invisible
galactique
le monstre spaghetti bolognaise
les extraterrestres si cher à nos
pyramidos préférées qui ont qui auraient
créé la vie voilà Prometheus là les
grands machins blancs là qui ont créé la
vie sur Terre dans le Film Prometheus il
faudra considérer que peut-être c'est
eux qui sont à l'origine de l'évolution
des espèces le problème c'est que à
partir du moment où tu ouvres la porte à
une théorie
irrationnel irrationnel dans le sens il
n'y a pas de preuve ni matériel ni
théorique ni rien du tout il y a aucune
raison de
d'imaginer qu'un gros doigt magique soit
venu pousser tout ça la voiture
fonctionne très bien donc à partir du
moment où tu ouvres la porte à la roue
de vélo qui sert à rien bah le problème
c'est que tu ouvres aussi la porte à une
bougie à un pot de fleur
je regarde ce que j'ai autour de moi au
placard un portrait
un interrupteur une poignée de porte une
fourchette Pikachu
et c'est pour ça que c'est considéré
comme étant non scientifique c'est parce
qu'à partir du moment où tu ouvres la
porte à des hypothèses
qui pour lesquelles on n'est pas on
n'aurait pas ouvert de porte de toute
façon parce qu'il y a pas de raison de
penser que que il y a de il y a même une
porte qui existe de toute façon
bah c'est la porte ouverte à toutes les
fenêtres justement
[Musique]
de L'Origine des espèces
une convention une définition de la
science qui excluait toute explication
basée sur une conception intelligente
c'est faux c'est faux la place la place
disait déjà bien abordable oui pourquoi
vous avez pas utilisé Dieu parce que
j'en avais pas besoin donc Pierre Simon
de Laplace voilà compte d'Empire 1749
1827 donc Darwin je rappelle l'origine
des espèces c'est 1859
qui a dit je n'ai pas eu besoin de cette
hypothèse voilà quand on lui a mentionné
Dieu pour je sais plus quoi ah oui
comment vous donner les lois de toute la
création et dans toute votre livre vous
ne parlez pas une seule fois de
l'existence de Dieu s'il répondit la
place je n'avais pas besoin de cette
hypothèse donc ça ne date pas je suis
quasiment sûr que ça n'avait que ça n'a
pas attendu la place pour être dit mais
la place est donc la preuve que c'était
là avant Darwin ce concept de on arrête
de faire appel à Dieu c'est à partir du
moment on a mis au point la méthode qui
deviendra aujourd'hui la méthode
scientifique
on essaye d'expliquer les choses sans
faire appel à des phénomènes magiques et
voilà c'est tout
voilà
pourtant et curieusement nous y compris
régulièrement l'intelligence constater
les effets de l'intelligence
seulement habituel
prenez par exemple
les meilleurs
ce symboles à des causes naturelles
telles que les tempêtes de sable ou
l'érosion